good morning everybody uh being 9 10 I'm
going to open up the public hearing on
House Bill 374 FN
which is relative to the application
process for driver's licenses and the
privacy of Motor Vehicle records before
we get started something I failed to do
last week if we can rise for the pledge
thank you
[Music]
um
Jay recognizes the prime sponsor of the
bill representative Sykes
thank you Mr chair members of the
transportation committee I am as you
just heard representative George Sykes
uh
Lebanon Ward 2 Grafton 14 is the
district which is a new district for me
and
um I'm here to introduce house bill 374.
um
the primary message that I would like to
impart to the committee is that first
and foremost this bill is about public
safety and the reason I say that is
because
based on the operating history of
multiple states of which there are more
than uh I think there's at least 17
States who have passed similar
legislation
one of the things that's been most
interesting about the passage of similar
bills is that for example in the state
of Connecticut where they have a similar
bill in in effect now and have for
several years
one of the very first things they
noticed was that the amount of Hit and
Run crashes where people get into a
minor motor vehicle accident and then
leave
dropped dramatically
and the reason is because we can presume
we don't have a we don't know why people
were fleeing earlier but we can presume
it's because they have a driver's
license instead of not and so that's a
really important Public Safety message
and beyond that this bill envisions the
opportunity to make sure that all of the
drivers
in the state of New Hampshire
have gone through the proper vetting
procedure from DMV meaning that they're
either qualified to get a driver's
license because they have one from
another state or because they have
they have come in and they've taken
their written exam showing their
familiarity with the laws of New
Hampshire and they have taken a
practical exam showing that they can
actually drive the car
successfully and so those are really
important considerations I would like to
believe that we as members of the
transportation committee are fully in
support of
um the good record that the DMV has
maintained from for keeping public
safety first and foremost in the state
with relative to Driver's Licenses
um
that's really the most important piece
that I wanted to get to spend the time
with you for uh to talk about and there
will be other folks who'll follow me who
will have more information for you
um but I'd be happy to entertain any
questions if uh if if I am able to
answer them
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair thank you um
when you tell people this in your
everyday walk around life what kind of
blowback do you get I mean what negative
comments would you get immediately on
this please
well I think the the best way I can
answer that representative Sinclair and
thank you for your question
um is that people do not really
understand
the primary purpose of the bill they get
they don't look into what what the real
thing is that they're TR that's trying
to be accomplished and so very
interesting I'll use as a a moral of the
story if you will
um last year when we when I introduced
this bill I had an excellent
conversation with them uh
uh member of the House from the
for me the other side of the aisle and
he just said to me well I can't vote for
this bill there's just no way
and then I spent some time and explained
to him what what I was trying to achieve
with the bill I spent some time with him
to
talk about details
at the end of which he said
oh
well I can support that bill and and in
fact at one point he was a co-sponsor
with me for one one time when I put this
bill in actually that conversation
happened
two terms ago
any further questions
seeing none they're letting off letting
you off the hook pretty easy
representative
mm-hmm
thank you
next up
uh in support of the bill looking for
four minutes to speak Maggie Fogerty
good morning thank you
my name is Maggie Fogarty I'm the New
Hampshire program director for the
American friends service committee which
is a Quaker founded organization working
on issues of justice and peace
throughout the world
and I'm also a representative of the New
Hampshire immigrant rights Network a
coalition of Advocates attorneys Faith
leaders and others who are trying to
promote Humane immigration policies in
the midst of the current chaos and
backlogs that currently characterize our
immigration system and that aren't doing
any of us any good much less immigrant
families in New Hampshire
uh and I'm here on behalf of that
immigrant rights Network to express our
strong support for HB 374 and I I have
written testimony which we've also
submitted by email so I'll just lift up
a few of our
um priority messages on this so this
bill as you likely understand would
simply allow people without Social
Security numbers
including undocumented immigrants living
in New Hampshire to apply for and obtain
New Hampshire driver licenses as long as
they qualify under every other category
of licensure in the state
um it's important to point out that
being undocumented is not in and of
itself a criminal offense it is a civil
offense
um but when people drive without a
license then that engages the criminal
legal system in ways that are not
um helpful for them or we would argue
for the criminal legal system
the primary benefit of this bill is that
it would increase Public Safety which is
a Bedrock obligation of the state to its
people
because undocumented residents are not
currently eligible for driver licenses
there's no systematic oversight of this
group of people so permitting licensure
for otherwise qualifying individuals and
their families would enable law
enforcement and other state agencies to
accurately and positively identify the
person there would be more effective
regulation of this group of Motor
Vehicle operators
there would be safer operation of Motor
Vehicles because the the license Holder
will have proven who they are where they
live and that they have passed the
required testing
and there would be an increase in
insured drivers which certainly doesn't
benefit only the Immigrant driver but
anybody they might encounter in a road
incident
we also believe that this bill removes
an unnecessary burden on law enforcement
who would need to prosecute actions of
driving without a license but in this
case that would remove that risk of that
unauthorized Behavior
it would decrease the fear of law
enforcement and immigrant communities
who often have good reason not to
cooperate even when their victims or
Witnesses of crime because of uh fear of
of what that engagement might mean to
them or their inability to demonstrate
their identification
and it would increase the well-being of
immigrant families in New Hampshire many
of whom and perhaps most of whom include
U.S citizen children Partners Etc most
of the Immigrant families in New
Hampshire are mixed status families
of the representative mentioned what are
some of the objections that we hear in
the community as we talk about the need
for this bill and certainly one that
comes up a lot is the fear of voter
fraud but we want to just lift up the
very obvious point that there are tens
of thousands of licensed drivers in New
Hampshire who are not eligible to vote
and our Municipal clerks know how to
handle that uh on voting day or when
receiving requests for absentee ballots
so it's it's more of a straw man than it
is
a real issue in New Hampshire
and also we also want to make it clear
that the possession of a driver's
license doesn't confer any federal or
state benefits for which a person might
uh otherwise be ineligible it is simply
saying that in New Hampshire if you can
prove who you are where you live and
that you've passed the required tests
that will give you a license to drive
legally on our roads and a way of
purchasing insurance
and I just want to lift up uh we have
experienced on a range of issues related
to immigrants lawfully present
immigrants primarily but all categories
of immigrants we have experienced such a
welcoming uh reception from the
Department of Safety and the Division of
Motor Vehicles who sincerely want our
driver license offices and other safety
initiatives to be receptive to people
regardless of their language needs
or encounters that they might have
within the system that are that are
confusing for them so we're hopeful for
an ongoing productive conversation with
them to continue as has been going on
especially in the past year and a half
so I'm happy to answer any questions you
might have to the best of my ability
thank you any questions from the
committee
See England thank you very much thank
you
next up
uh chair recognizes Eva Castillo
Castillo representing herself in support
of the bill looking for three minutes
thank you
good morning
my name is Eva Castillo I'm a resident
of Manchester I'm an immigrant rights
Advocate I have been here in New
Hampshire since
and part of my job is to Advocate but I
also serve as a police commissioner in
Manchester and not that I'm speaking I'm
not speaking on behalf of the commission
but part of my role is to build
relationships between police and the
community like Maggie referred the
community are fearful of the police for
different reasons because the police for
the most part in our countries are not
what you see here they are not decent
human beings like here and it doesn't
work right so we come here with all
those things so I'm here to speak in
favor of this bill with which which
would remove the barriers of immigration
status in obtaining a driver's license
in New Hampshire the current rules
deprive long-standing citizens and
members not in our community of a Modern
Life necessity a driver's license New
Hampshire has a really bad
transportation system and most of our
immigrants are here in the prime working
years of their lives
the the characteristic of their jobs
they work mostly in service in the
service area so they can there's no
option for them to work remotely so they
all have
to drive
to to work they will have to drive to to
do their daily chores maintaining
immigration registrations to driver's
license eligibility guarantees that a
that there's hundreds of drivers taking
the risk of driving without a license
and potentially endangering themselves
and others because the state leaves them
no alternative
they they do drive but they do not have
the training and they don't have the
license the police officers have no clue
who they're dealing with when they stop
them they have to have somebody else
register their car uh they so they're
more likely to lie or just flee the
scene of an accident because they they
just are not going to face the police so
as a matter of public safety don't you
want people to to be vetted to to to
know who they are to make sure that they
know the rules of the road to make sure
they pass the driver's ed test so that
would put the whole community
in a much safer place and you know it is
a pragmatic issue of a public safety
problem right now we have no clue who is
driving who's in our roads and what
their capacity is to to really figure
out what to do uh when something goes
wrong or if they're really who say if
they're really who they they say they
are so our communities will be safer
when every uh person is a licensed
driver and Maggie touch on the point of
concerns about voting and I've heard
that too I came into this country in
1976 as a student so I was on an F1 Visa
I've have always had a driver's license
since I came here I have worked in every
single election as a volunteer for the
Immigrant Community since I came first
in Michigan and then in New Hampshire I
was not a citizen I could not vote and I
would never even consider I had never
heard anybody that is a student or is in
any type of Visa that allows them to
have a
driver's license even consider voting I
became a citizen in the late 90s and
that was the first time in my life that
I was able to vote and it was the
greatest day in my life I went straight
from the courthouse here in Concord to
City Hall in Manchester not even stop
for coffee to register to vote because
after so many years of not being able to
do it and trying to motivate those that
had the right to exercise that right you
know so there's already balance checks
and balances in place and rest assured
that you know that's not going to be the
case
so thank you and I hope you consider
this bill favorably and I second the
kudos to the DMV and to the Department
of Safety they have really reached a
really uh across the the aisle they had
really made open conversations with us
and makes a made us feel like we can
trust and we have you know a trusting
relationship and respectful relationship
with them that those that does not
happen with many other offices thank you
questions thank you any questions from
the committee
representative Staub thank you for
taking my question
I'm curious
um
I don't really understand
who exactly this would cover for example
people who have applied for Refugee
status are they eligible to get driver's
license while they're waiting to have
their um
their uh
get get processed there are a bunch of
people that are not eligible to have to
have social security
like students you know people are in the
process of adjusting their status to a
permanent thing this would apply to them
too as well as the people that really do
not have uh any any other means of
adjusting their status but we have tons
of mixed status families where the
children are U.S citizens by birth that
may be one of the parents is a legal
permanent resident and the other one is
undocumented so that would help a lot of
those people too okay thank you
what are the questions from the
committee representative Saint Claire I
have a question for you is anybody from
the DMV or their State Police or anybody
else going to testify unless I do not
have anybody signed up at this point
I would like to ask a question that I
probably should have asked
representative Sykes but
it was it was testified that other
states have this already in place I
believe Connecticut was one of them so
if those people have a driver's license
in Connecticut and they're not
documented
up are they in fact allowed to drive in
New Hampshire now with that license
but they are residents of Connecticut so
I should suppose if they come to the
White Mountains for vacation they are
allowed to to drive in New Hampshire
that's a valid license but they're not
they're but they're not residents of New
Hampshire we're we're just trying to get
people that reside in New Hampshire to
be able to drive I understand that I
just wanted to be clear about that thank
you
any other questions from the committee
England thank you very much thank you
have a great day
foreign
next up Neil Kirk representing himself
opposed to the bill
greetings
greetings Mr chairman to you and to
members of the committee for the record
I am Neil Kirk I live in the town of
where
and I am here representing myself I
oppose this bill
um
there are there were statements made
that the purpose of this bill is to
promote Public Safety and some
statistics were given from the state of
Connecticut
um I think the committee has a
responsibility to further investigate
whether there is a connection between
these kinds of additional licenses and
public safety for example in Connecticut
was the time period involved comparing
pre-covered
traffic statistics with covid traffic
statistics because we all know that
during covet fewer people were driving
so one would expect all sorts of driving
statistics to be lower during covet than
they were otherwise
if in fact there were 17 states that
have this there's a great D there should
be a great deal of information
to support or refute that claim and I
hope the committee will investigate that
um
secondly I oppose this bill because it
encourages people who have
violated American laws illegal
immigrants or undocumented immigrants to
settle in New Hampshire
that is to say
by facilitating an identification
document as well as a driver's license
because this bill does say that the
driver's license must be accepted as
identification
we are encouraging a group of people who
violated our laws to settle in our state
I don't think that's good policy for New
Hampshire but that's something I think
the committee should consider
um
I'd like to go over a couple of the
provisions of the bill
um to
suggest to support my position
section one which begins on page one
line 14.
um
purports to deny access to anyone
seeking to identify the type of license
one holds standard or real ID compliant
but it takes away that protection by
allowing the information to be given out
on the basis of a subpoena a subpoena
can be granted to just about anyone and
doesn't require probable cause it's a
very low standard so if in fact the
ideas for protection here you might want
to reconsider that provision
section 3ec page one starting on page
one line 15.
um
supports this because it requires a
warrant supported by probable cause
in order for DMV to give data to
immigration law enforcement officials
um Section 3 Ed starting on page one
line 25
requires a person who receives data from
DMV that it isn't used for import in
excuse me immigration enforcement
purposes but there's an exception
pursuant to a Cooperative Arrangement
between agencies such that the
arrangement does not enforce immigration
law there's a five-year record-keeping
requirement and a five thousand dollar
civil penalty
uh it seems that there's a whole group
of Provisions in here in this build
which prevent immigration people from
getting access to this information so
that presumably to encourage people to
register get light illegal aliens to
register and get licenses and be exempt
or prevent law immigration law
enforcement people from acquiring
information about them and using it and
I understand that that makes sense if
this is going to support a public safety
provision but there are all sorts of
ramifications Beyond Public Safety that
I think the committee should consider do
we really want MS-13 folks getting
driver's licenses in New Hampshire
you MS-13 is that criminal gang that
operates
in various Central American countries
um
section three starting on page two line
26.
allows drivers license to be used not
just for mission for permission to
operate a vehicle but as I said as a
form of identification
for all purposes
that legitimates the presence of an
illegal immigrant
in New Hampshire is that good public
policy for us
um
I would suggest as some of the other
Witnesses have mentioned that this bill
really
involves voting or at least questions of
voting and perhaps it should go to
election law as a second committee if it
should pass this committee and the house
floor
I just raised that issue
in some these sections of the bill
help New Hampshire in becoming a
sanctuary state
for undocumented or illegal immigrants
the prime reason however why I'm
testifying against this bill has to do
with Section 6 and 7 dealing it's a page
three line 30.
it requires an applicant for a non-real
ID license
to provide his social security number
or pay a fine of 150 dollars
now as some of you may know I'm very
concerned about privacy issues and one
of the ways you protect your privacy is
by keeping your social security number
out of the hands of government
this bill
would charge me and anyone else who
feels as I do a hundred fifty dollars to
maintain that privilege
I have three reasons why this is bad a
bad provision and should be stricken
from this bill even if the rest of it is
to pass
first there's no connection connection
between the amount of the fee and the
cost of providing the service that DMV
would do in not including your social
security number in the form
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has said
that for a fee to be legal
it must cover only two things number one
the cost of the service plus 25 percent
because sometimes you can't accurately
figure out the cost of the service
I'd be willing to bet my house
that it's not going to cost
DMV 150 to plug in a number or not plug
in a number on a form
so I believe this is on an
unconstitutional fee which would make it
a tax
and as a tax it doesn't meet the
requirements of our constitution so it's
illegal
secondly
this provision violates the
informational privacy Amendment to the
New Hampshire Constitution which the
folks the people of this state adopted
it by an 81 percent vote in 2018 that's
part first article 2B
in that the government is in effect
through an outrageously disproportionate
fee requiring individuals to provide
personal information to the government
without it being absolutely essential
and the only way the government could
achieve a legitimate governmental
purpose
we cannot require information of
citizens under that Amendment unless
there is an essential government purpose
for it and the only way
the government can achieve that purpose
is by requiring that information
I don't think
this meets those requirements
and finally
I believe it's bad public policy to
coerce New Hampshire residents
financially
to maintain their privacy
I just don't think that's in the New
Hampshire tradition
thank you Mr chairman that completes my
testimony and if there are any questions
from the committee members I'd be
pleased to try to answer them thank you
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair good morning
um
just out of curiosity you obviously have
a lot of reasons why you're not in favor
of this pill but have you reached out to
the DMV or the state police and asked
their opinion of of this
no I haven't because the issues the the
stated purpose of the bill
is to
um or excuse me what this Prime sponsor
said representative Sykes was for Public
Safety
that has not been my primary concern my
primary concern on this bill is the
Privacy issue which is really not part
of the State Police or the DMV
um
concern to some extent DMV would like to
have social security numbers because it
allows them to do certain other things
but there are workarounds for them to do
these other things they don't have to
have social security numbers and they've
survived very well for decades without
them okay so I didn't contact the State
Police or DMV because my concern was not
related to their issues okay thanks
foreign
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman
well having nobody else signed up to
speak I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 374.
our next hearing is on House Bill 375 FN
at 10 o'clock
being 10 o'clock I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill 375 FN
relative to the licensure of
non-resident aliens temporarily residing
in New Hampshire
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Sykes
Mr chairman members of the
transportation committee I am
representative George Sykes
Grafton 14 which I represent Lebanon
Ward 2. as I said previously that's a
new Ward that's a new district for me
um I'd like to thank you for giving me
this opportunity to present this bill to
you
um
I want to start out before I get into
the nuts and bolts of the the bill
I wanted to spend a moment just to tell
you a personal story and then maybe
provide some illumination about why I've
gone down this road no pun intended of
trying to work on various drivers
license issues
[Music]
um
some of you may know this some of you
may not know this but for
with two days notice
I was asked to go to the country of
Haiti
two days three days after the earthquake
and there I went I was supposed to be
there for a month I ended up being there
for nearly two years by the time
everything was done during that time I
began as a person doing working on their
cash transfer program I then became a
logistics person and finally became
director of facilities for the all the
Red Cross facilities in the country
during that time
I witnessed
some disturbing things
whether it's starving babies standing on
the street corner dead bodies in the
street people
absolutely afraid about what's going on
I saw most of that they may not have
been shooting at me personally but
literally was shot at a couple of times
during my time there
and all the time my Good Wife kept
saying yes when they asked me to stay
longer which is why that one month
became almost two years
during that time
I had a young man work for me in the
logistics side of things and
um we paid him the princely sum of three
hundred dollars a month which was a lot
of money actually then this this is now
10 almost 11 years ago
um he and I became very close working
um
Partners if you will
colleagues that's a better word and
um one of the jobs that I had him do for
me was that
under Haitian labor law
you either hired somebody after two
weeks or you hired them for the day paid
them that day and then they went home so
because when you're trying to get
supplies into a country that has
virtually no infrastructure you could
couldn't be guaranteed that
the for example for the cholera response
the
one million cases of soap would arrive
on a particular day but when it did
start arriving you had to have the help
so we would hire temporary day workers
there were no forklifts etc etc it was
each case one person in a chain
unloading these trucks
but at the end of the day those workers
had to be paid and
um
the young man's name is beeswood
beeswood would be the one who would pay
them this is important piece because
after I left Haiti I lost track lost
track of him and uh
about
seven years ago now so two years after I
left Haiti I got a call
from beeswood and he said
I've just sent my family out of the
country
because
to the U.S on uh they had visas in order
to and a passport Haitian passport in
order to come
I just sent them out of the country
because it's not safe here for me
anymore and he proceeded to tell me how
he and two other friends the three of
them
were discovered if you will by the gangs
and
they murdered one of his friends and
they kidnapped beeswood and then they
tried to extort the money
because
for their eyes here was a guy was
handing out cash
in the past
so they thought he had money well of
course he didn't
um and so the good news is that he was
able to escape his kidnappers the bad
news is that when that typically would
happen
The Gangs would then find
that person and his or her family and
murder them as well so there were no
Witnesses and so he needed to flee the
country
and
we working with some church groups we
were able to get him out of again
legally into the United States and when
he got here he then applied for himself
and his family for Asylum status
perfectly acceptable way and route to go
the way the process works is you can go
you you can you if you move into New
Hampshire or any other state in the
United States you can apply for Asylum
through the federal government
they give you a for lack of a better
term a receipt that says you've applied
for Asylum and when when possible
there'll be a hearing to see whether
your request for Asylum is a legitimate
one
we are now seven years waiting still for
that hearing seven years
in the meantime
he doesn't have any work authorization
so he can't work he can't support his
family but at least they're safe and
they will survive
the way the system further works on the
federal government side of things is
that after
365 days one year
if you have not had your hearing you
will get
work authorization
which he then received a year later
once in possession of that work
authorization
he could then go apply for a driver's
license take his tests and receive a New
Hampshire driver's license and we all
know here in rural Northern New
Hampshire and by the way bees would move
to Lebanon where I had gathered a church
group to help support him and his family
while he was waiting to get his work
permit
and so now he has a driver's license the
problem is from my perspective
and what this bill attempts to address
is
New Hampshire law states that you must
if you move into New Hampshire you have
60 days to after 60 days you have to
have your New Hampshire driver's license
but in his case and in other asylis
cases
they can't apply for the driver's
license there's no provision for them to
get a driver's license at that time at
that time and
this bill attempts to close the gap
between the 60 days when they should get
a driver's license and the 365 days that
has to go take place before they can
qualify for that driver's license that's
all this bill is trying to do
um there I will tell you that there are
some developments
in terms of this we'll we continue to
have discussions with the DMV about how
to best affect this but in the meantime
the I had submitted the bill and it may
be that it will ultimately require a
legislative fix that's what this was
about just trying to close the gap
and with that
um I'll entertain any questions
thank you representative any questions
from the committee representative Gorski
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Sykes for taking my
question
um you mentioned here you know
temporarily residing in New Hampshire
can you define what temporarily means
so I I believe that um in the instance
of the the kind of thing that I was
trying to describe to you for an asyli
request they are temporarily here until
their Asylum hearing it could be
a matter of a couple of years or a year
it could be seven
I can't Define that more accurately
because I don't control the federal
immigration system and how how soon or
how fast the person will get their day
in court to prove whether they deserve
the right to be accepted as an asylum
and get permanent
uh non-citizen status in the country and
oh by the way thank you for the question
uh representative one other thing I
would add that I think is pertinent to
this is
in the intervening time since he got his
driver's license
um
beeswood
his two children and his wife still
reside in Lebanon
both his wife and he work he is
currently a program manager for a local
non-profit called listen which US many
folks may already be aware of so he is a
productive
you part of our city he also is a
volunteer with one of the commissions
that the city has he's fully engaged as
a not as a resident although a
non-citizen resident of our of our city
and our state and that only became
possible when he could work and when he
could drive
because we all know rural Northern New
Hampshire has a terror not a really
great
public transportation system
for the questions from the committee
representative Sinclair
thank you Mr chair and um he's working
beeswood is working so I take he's uh
paying Social Security and uh state
state business tax or what not business
tax but um Medicare and all all the ETC
you are correct he is paying Social
Security and and all the other things
that come out of one's paycheck
any other questions from the committee
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
I'm looking through this uh bill here
and it's on D it's a is is your intent
to have this license only good for 180
days or is it 180 days
renewed and then every up to five years
all right that's a great question thank
you for that so the intent is for it to
be a temporary license until they can
get their work permit and to close that
Gap from 60 days to 365 days and that's
not that unusual we have lots of folks
who are non-citizens who have a Visa for
instance who are here
and they are eligible for a driver's
license and they get one but when their
visa expires so does the driver's
license and I I'm not sure I'm hopeful I
can have the exact numbers but we're
talking about tens of thousands of
people who have that type of driver's
license which is essentially temporary
any other questions
I've got one representative
once they have an asylum Seeker has
their receipt
and whether this passes or not you say
if it doesn't they've been waited after
a year they get their work permit if
this passes they can get it immediately
assuming it's good for 180 days what
happens after 180 days if they still
haven't gone to their hearing yet do
they have to reapply
for another driver's license another
temporary
well they they wouldn't have
at 365 days the federal government will
automatically give the person their work
permit which will then allow them to
apply for a driver's license under the
normal system
so
if it expires because they're not well
let's say for the sake of discussion
they they've had their hearing and
they're not approved while the driver's
license will go away
but again very narrow focus on this bill
is to just close that Gap
because I I guess I just would ask you
to think about how
you live in a place where there's no
public transportation to speak of
you willing able and want to work but
the system is that you have to wait 365
days
and how do you get
for instance
these Woodworks for listen
that listen is Lebanon in service to
every neighbor that's an acronym for
that organization
they provide lots of services to people
who need them how do you get to them if
you live up off of the bus route
how do you get there to get food
that is available to to pretty much
anybody who might need it
if you don't have a car and you can't
get there you have to depend on somebody
to take you
imagine having to depend on people
taking you everywhere you needed to go
whether it's a doctor's appointment
and
whether it's to get food or medicine for
your family and you have to depend on
outside folks
that's a challenge
I see it as a
an unnecessary challenge if we can
legally get they're here legally and
they'll have an opportunity to legally
get a driver's license
thank you and let me try my follow-up on
my own behalf I understand you're trying
to close the gap I I I I I see that but
I even the way the bill is written I
still see a gap of 185 days if the
license expires after 180 waiting for
that work permit that comes after 365.
180 and 60 is how many days okay there's
the 60s in that too okay
yeah
that's you see where I'm getting at well
now I see now I see a question but the
point I'm trying to make to you is that
that it's like 180 days
Gap not because they can't they can't
apply for a driver's license any sooner
than that they according to the DMV at
the time this bill was written thank you
and again we're working on that we you
know we're always open to suggestions
and
um ways to make
solve problems for our neighbors isn't
that what we do as legislators listen to
our neighbors problems and try and find
Solutions yep any other questions from
the committee representative Fox
thank you Mr chair
um as a follow-up to your question just
so that I understand
um a person coming in and seeking Asylum
there's the 60 days
um if this bill passes we will be they
will be able to apply for a driver's
license that is uh 180 day driver's
license that is temporary so we have the
three months there the two months
they've been here that's five months
what happens if they still don't
um don't receive their permit we still
have seven more months
will they reapply will they
yeah you're right it is a there's a
still a gap there I'm trying to remember
this bill was written as you see it
um in conjunction with the former
director of DMV director baleki and I
forget I apologize I must be getting
senile in my old age
um I can't quite remember but I think
that is probably part of the process
where they can reapply you know prove
that they're still here prove that they
haven't got their work permit yet but
they that they're still on track to do
so
and I stand to be corrected about that
well ideally
they would get their permit and wouldn't
have to reapply but
um but there is that Gap so I'll I'll uh
go back to my notes from last year maybe
we can yeah and I think it's something
we can look into as well yeah
thank you any other questions from the
committee
I have one more for you representative
um
you said that if they are unsuccessful
getting their Asylum granted the license
just goes away can you what what exactly
does that mean because my question is
what happens if they're denied Asylum
well that's the purpose of making it a
temporary driver's license so that it's
gonna it's gonna go away of its own
accord anyway it's something the DMV is
they watch people who are Visa holders
and when the Visa expires the license
expires it's a normal practice for them
thank you any other questions
see you then thank you very much
um next up the chair recognized Maggie
Fogarty uh in support of the bill
seeking three minutes this time versus
the four you asked for last time
uh in support of the bill if I did
mention
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Maggie Fogerty I'm
the New Hampshire program director for
the American friends service committee
and convener of the New Hampshire
immigrant rights Network and we are here
in support of HB 375 we have written
testimony uh with more detail but I'll
just lift up some some key themes
so Asylum petition adjudications are
complicated and they have historically
taken extended periods of time before
the government issues a decision
so built into the process is the
opportunity currently for an asylum
Seeker after a period of 150 days to
request work authorization EAD
employment authorization documents
because that document comes with a
social security number the person can
then go to the DMV and apply for a
license
but what we've seen now over the last
several years is that once that
application is made at 150 days the wait
time which would normally be about six
months has taken a year or even a year
and a half so it's a very protracted
period of waiting for an opportunity to
uh to become an authorized worker which
this bill doesn't address at all and an
authorized driver
and New Hampshire people are very aware
of this phenomenon because for the past
seven or eight years and plenty of times
historically as well but robustly in the
past seven or eight years communities
have organized themselves into local and
Regional host home and Hospitality
networks in keen and the Upper Valley
and Nashua Manchester conquered the
Lakes Region and the Seacoast and I'm
probably leaving somebody out
providing
Hospitality perhaps in a church or in
somebody's home or gathering resources
for an apartment and then providing a
lot of wraparound supports for the
Asylum seeking family and so we're much
more acutely aware of this very
protracted wait period than we might
otherwise be because it wouldn't impact
our lives directly and what we see in
every instance is that people as
representative Sykes mentioned people
are exhausted by being dependent upon
others for their and their family's own
well-being there is such a desire I
think every healthy person I know wants
to be able to care for themselves care
for their family's needs and act
independently and to not be able to
drive or to uh to work create just a
long period of a lot of nice people
helping you but not a lot of privacy and
Independence for that family family so
so this bill by bridging that Gap in
what I understand to be a renewable
license until a more permanent option is
available gives that household a lot
more Independence for taking their
children to school or to medical
appointments or grocery shopping Etc so
we see this as a common sense proposal
coming out of our experience walking
with Asylum Seekers who are legally
present in the United States going
through the proper channels to request
Asylum here and so we hope for your
support
thank you questions from the committee
seeing then thank you very much thank
you
uh next up the chair recognizes Eva
Castille in support of the bill seeking
two minutes to speak
fair enough thank you very much
well seeing no other people signed up to
speak uh on House Bill 375 I want to
close the public hearing
uh we do have a delay till our next one
11 o'clock keep in mind we had many more
people testifying on these bills last
time perhaps it's the weather that's why
I did give it an hour so uh we'll be
back at 11 for host Bill
597.
foreign
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee
I am representative Charlotte dilorenzo
I represent Newmarket in new fields in
the New Hampshire house in Rockingham
District 10.
as a co-sponsor of this bill I am here
to sit in for representative David Muse
the prime sponsor of the bill and I only
need probably five to seven minutes to
speak
I will be brief because I know that
representative Muse prepared and sent
all of you an email with the testimony
so I will begin
now HB 597 would do two things first it
would require the Department of Motor
Vehicles to include a person's race and
ethnicity on newly issued New Hampshire
driver's licenses and non-driver's
identification cards
second it would require law enforcement
agencies when possible to collect gender
race and ethnicity data along with town
of residence from a driver's license or
other state issued identification card
when a person is arrested
cited are subjected to a field stopper
warning including a motor vehicle stop
that did not lead to a citation
the bill also includes an opt-out
provision that allows someone with
privacy concerns who doesn't wish to
share their racial ethnicity data to opt
out from sharing it
as you know this is not the first time
the legislature has considered these
measures
in 2020 the governor's Commission on law
enforcement accountability community and
transparency also known as the LA act
commission unanimously recommended a
series of data collection member
measures intended to gather data on
potential racial profiling by law
enforcement in New Hampshire
all of the commission's recommendations
were endorsed in August of 2020 by
Governor Christopher sununu among the
recommendations 23 and 24 both required
legislation and both are covered under
the scope of the bill before you today
if you're feeling a little bit of
legislative Deja Vu today it may be
because SBC
96 an ominous police Reform Bill that
was eventually signed into law by the
governor started out including these
Provisions but prior to the sending the
bill over to the house the Senate
stripped out these measures in its place
a legislative committee was created to
study the issue
as it turns out the study commission's
page and a half report from November of
um
there were discussions around the pluses
and minuses of an opt-out provision that
were summarized as was the need for the
state to pick up any additional cost for
system changes
which were undetermined at that time and
any cost to implement the changes
incurred by municipalities
the committee recommended one
establishing an ad hoc committee to
continue working the issue with the
Department of Safety and two amending a
referred Bill to create another study
committee to continue working the issue
well another study committee was never
apparently created we've learned from
the Dos assistant commissioner Eddie
Edwards that the department has
continued to discuss data collection
behind the scenes this is a reason why
instead of the cost of the changes being
classified as indeterminable as they
were a few years ago the department was
able to estimate the cost of the system
changes needed to implement the bill at
108 thousand dollars
while representative the Dos can tell
you more about how those costs would
break down the bill is an investment in
the reputation of our state and if the
Specter of racial profiling is ever
going to be addressed in any meaningful
way
both the state and the public are going
to need reliable information on their
race and ethnicity of the people who are
being stopped
this that is what HB 597 is all about it
offers a simple reliable way to
accurately collect prevalent data
without asking police officers to guess
that is the end of my testimony
um if and I'm open to questions thank
you
thank you representative any questions
from the committee
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
maybe I missed it why do we want to
collect this data
why do you want them to collect the data
well to determine whether there is ratio
profiling in um traffic stops Etc in New
Hampshire
what are the questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much
um did you have written testimony or was
that representative music the written
testimony was um emailed to you all by
representative Muse thank you again all
right thank you
you have to bear with me help me out
with a couple of these names uh next up
in support of the bill seeking five
minutes uh Buzz
sure
come on up thank you representing
himself again in support of the bill
I'm a law professor at uh UNH School of
Law uh I was a public defender for 13
years in New Hampshire before I became a
law professor 30 years ago
I am also a elected Police Commissioner
in Portsmouth uh what I have to say
today is my own opinion it does not
reflect the opinion one way or another
of unh UNH School of Law or the
Portsmouth police commission I want that
clear and I'm in support of this bill I
won't repeat uh representative De
Lorenzo said but I think the key here is
data collection
um I uh you know we've been talking
about the issue of racial profiling for
a while now both in the legislature and
publicly uh particularly uh it was a
real this long discussion and important
discussion in the liac commission and
now some here we'll talk about that uh
but the underlying issue is we can talk
about it forever but we need data
and the court system Prosecutor's
offices police departments with some
exceptions
are not collecting the data so it all
turns into talk without data and that's
from my perspective in addition to
giving people the option of putting race
and ethnicity on their on their driver's
license uh collecting data so we can
sort this out it's really important I
will point out that uh there are uh
a number of police departments in New
Hampshire that are Kalia certified and
there is a measure of data Rec data
collection requirements under Khalia but
it's not comprehensive for example it
does not collect ethnicity data it
collects only race data
and uh
the the designation of Hispanic is not a
race it's an ethnicity
and so uh what I have heard and seen is
police departments don't know what to do
when a person they identify or a person
self-identifies as a Hispanic some put
it in the category of caucasians some
put it in the category of black
so even those departments where there's
not that many in New Hampshire that are
clear certified in are collecting some
of this data are not collecting uh good
data in that regard Portsmouth uh police
department which I'm most familiar with
is purchasing what's called a new CAD
RMS system that is uh the the software
system for all the data that they have
in the police department and it's a part
of that the police commission has has
voted uh to adopt some proposals from
the community that requires that
demographic very specific demographic
data be collected and my understanding
is it'll be the first police department
in New Hampshire that will more
comprehensively collect data and uh
and and I I expect that will be helpful
but data is everything and I know you
know as Representatives you a lot of
people coming in front of you with
opinions about this about that and my
guess is
they carry more weight and you make
better legislation when you have hard
data when you have numbers rather than
just who talks the best
um so I encourage everyone on this
committee to support this bill
and more than willing to answer
questions
thank you sir
that's the main question I have about
this bill so I'll ask you first
data is important we use data for
everything to make the best judgments we
can and that's my concern that the data
you're going to be collecting is on an
optional basis
so if it's a small picture of the data
because it's optional how can it be
considered reliable
well um
let me answer it this way
the data we're going to collect in
Portsmouth about
race and ethnicity
is the is not just based on driver's
license
uh it will be based on the perception of
the officer remember the issue here
is the perception in terms of racial
profiling or the risk of racial
profiling the issue is how the officer
perceives the race or ethnicity of the
individual it's that's the most
important thing because out of that may
emphasis on the word may arise
racial profiling
um I mean there is evidence out there
that uh there's issues uh with that kind
of data collection and so the driver's
license information
helps in part to clear some of that up I
know of at least three examples in New
Hampshire of individuals who are clearly
black
being stopped and having an encounter
with the police
and later availability of police reports
indicates that the police officers put
the individual down as Caucasian as
white
uh I don't think that's a rampant
problem but the combination of
being required to put down your
perception of the race or ethnicity of
the individual and having a driver's
license uh that admittedly optional and
we'll see how many people have Avail
themselves of that option the
combination of those will give us better
data data we're not going to have freely
admit we're never going to get perfect
data but we got no data right now
any other questions from the committee
see you then thank you again thank you
um Jay recognizes Eva Castillo
representing herself in support of the
bill looking for a couple of minutes to
chime in thank you
hi again
um Edward Castillo I live in Manchester
like I said before I am an activist and
I'm an immigrant rights Advocate but
also I work a lot with the police in
addition to being a police commissioner
in Manchester I'm not speaking on behalf
of the Communist police cognition so
um I was the chair of the
disproportional minority contact
Committee of Manchester for the SAG the
state Advisory Group for Juvenile
Justice
when it existed about 10 years ago for a
few years and it was a nightmare
to to get data we did not have enough
data
so I really feel it is needed to
prove that our police departments really
in the last few years have really made
an effort
to be
unbiased we all have bias as all of us
but building relationships and part of
my role is to build relationships and I
have gone all over the state talking to
all kinds of police departments just to
to build relationships with them and to
and for it has been a two-way education
process me educated myself about police
issues but at the same time educating
them about the particular issues that we
immigrants face uh I like the idea of
ethnicity because I am not a I'm married
on the surface uh you would see me as a
white person but I'm a Latina person and
I don't identify myself as white and I
would never put myself white I just
leave that question blank or I put order
and I put human but I don't I don't
identify that I never really liked the
fact that we had to be asked about race
in a country where race is supposed to
not be an issue anywhere in anything but
at the same time the more I worked with
so many in so many venues the more I see
the purpose of it and this is it to just
make sure that we're collecting making
sure that we're treating everybody
equally and and I change my position and
yes it is voluntary but at the same time
we all have to play a role in the
community to explain to all the
communities why is this question needed
a lot of the Dominicans are Latinos but
they are black in race and they would
never put themselves as black they have
they put themselves as Latinos so
ethnicity is also very important and I
am in full support of this because we do
have great police departments here and
we they trying to do the right thing
they're individuals in every single
group that have their biases but I'm
sure that uh
with with this data we're gonna see a
lot of the good stuff that is happening
in our communities thank you
thank you questions from the committee
CNN thank you again
excuse me
uh next up
I'm going to try this again uh in
support of the bill representing the
ACLU Joseph lassazz
thank you sir come on down
excuse me sir did you have a card filled
out too
I'm here just to find additional
testimony as another thing to install
you well if you're going to provide some
testimony I do need you to fill out one
of these for me I'm happy to have been
my amend that with adding my name after
that no you can do your own okay
thank you Mr Cheryl
good morning members my name is Joseph
viscaz and I will be representing the
ACLU of New Hampshire in support of HB
597 I will also be representing various
criminal justice stakeholders in New
Hampshire in support of this
this recommendation was something that
was born out of a concern that came
during the liac commission which I
served on Governor sununu appointed this
commission to take a look at New
Hampshire law enforcement and look for
ways of improving it uh in New Hampshire
as we spent many months on this uh
commission and analyzing different parts
this this recommendation came forward
uh due to a couple things that involved
concerns over individuals who felt that
they were being profiled and when the
data was trying to be researched it was
not complete it was inconclusive and it
led to gaps um in in certain assessments
of the system
this concern was brought to the state
police who did take uh steps to to
ensure that where they started doing
data collection neighbors is a federal
uh based uh system that requires uh this
type of data collection and so they have
it publicly available on their website
only 154 departments though are
reporting to this system and again this
is an issue when you are trying to
analyze the system as a whole and you're
looking for ways of improving it
so ensuring this passing this
legislation would be more than just
about uh racial profiling and data
collection it would be about analyzing
the system as a whole and looking for
ways that we could improve it in New
Hampshire
there has been concerns that have been
brought to the ACLU I've uh you heard
testimony earliest today about
individuals who uh clearly were not the
demographic that they were identified or
labeled as I was one of those
individuals
excuse me in 2021 I was followed for
over a mile
um by an officer who pulled me over
right as I was crossing into the next
County uh into the next uh Town Line uh
and after after a long discussion with
this officer on the side of the road
where it was apparent that um
I was being just uh fished for as I was
on my way to work I was let go and I
went on my way when I did a 91a request
on that stop because I felt that the
stop was not
um
to the standard of what it should have
been I was put down as a Caucasian male
I don't know uh
how I was identified that way or not but
I think that that that raised some
concerns and then we started to see that
that also had been happening in other uh
parts of the state this is also
happening nationally and I can submit
some information on that after the
committee is interested in that as well
so this was all brought up and this
recommendation came forward to try to
address those concerns this was
unanimously agreed upon by both the
community and the law enforcement
Community as well so to have both of
them together and not have this
legislation passed is very shocking I am
happy to answer any questions that you
may have on this
thank you thank you sir any questions
from the committee representative
sellers thank you Mr chair
with with
what's going on today and our age is
I can I can identify as
a black person and have that on my
license
and and I I just don't understand I'm
trying to figure out
how will that help data collection
that's a great question
So currently uh what is considered the
gold standard in New Hampshire is Kalia
it is an accreditation system that
police departments use and they all
strive to go for this standard
Kalia requires this type of data
collection in their standards and there
has there was even talks about moving
towards a more uniformed measure across
the state that all departments would
operate under that same standard even if
they couldn't be Khalia accredited due
to either Financial
restrictions or signs of departments
having this data what it does is it
allows you to look at the system as a
whole and while you I know when you said
I I don't know if you were referencing
yourself specifically as identifying as
by if you were if you were to do that
um at the department of safety I think
that
that would there there would be a
violation for that because those those
when you are at the way that the system
would work is that an individual when
they would go to get their license
um at time of renewal or when they were
originally there would be a a code that
would have it it wouldn't be something
that would actually be printed on your
license and it could Auto populate when
the officer went to their vehicle to um
scan the the license onto their system
if a person is going to the Department
of Safety and misidentifying themself on
official documents I can't speak to this
I think that the Attorney General's
office here and department of safety
that could be but I think that that
would actually be a violation because
you're you would not be allowed to
um to lie on on on your documents that
you're submitting to the Department of
Safety again this is about looking at
multiple things this is about looking at
Trends patterns statistics it's also
about ensuring how is the system working
in each area and how can we bring it up
if you see it in one area of New
Hampshire that things are going well
then other departments can share
information on work this is a this is
not to to form a system to have a odd
got you here a moment that is not what
this is about this is about a tool this
committee makes decisions based on data
and facts they do not make decisions off
the top of their head and so
that's what this is this is about adding
tools to our system of analysis to be
able to ensure that we have an equitable
and fair system in New Hampshire
any other questions follow-up
yeah thank you
um
do you have data today on New Hampshire
police departments that seems to be an
issue that's why you want this on the
driver's license
oh
seems to be an issue in which what do
you mean by seems to be an issue if I
may ask so I want to know what data what
data you actually have is do you have
any data that there are any problems
with police departments in New Hampshire
uh
doing inappropriate identification of
people besides here and there and what
might have happened already
like to yourself and
uh I would consider the Lori list
um public data on whether or not that
those in those situations are happening
what are the questions from the
committee representative View
so it sounds like there are two parts
that's the part where the officer
reports their impression
of the ethnicity of the race but it's
also self-reported by the person on
their license or in their database in in
their data so if the two things don't
match it would there would be some kind
of trigger to
dig a Little Deeper as to why the it was
misreported or you know maybe just
didn't fill his paperwork right and
checked the wrong box or something like
that so it would give you kind of a
Fail-Safe to
to say is that kind of why there's two
parts to it with the
that's that's a great question
representative so I think that it
there's there is two parts to that so
the the first part is that uh this
information is required of the officer
and so when you when you think of a
situation of an officer pulling us and
it's we can all I don't know if we can
all relate to it but you get pulled over
by an officer that's already
um a little bit of a contentious
situation you don't know why you're
being pulled over and so it's it's not
it was seen as a concern to it's not
fair for an officer to have to then ask
an individual while they're playing hey
by the way uh what do you identify as
too like that could just lead to you
know or further exacerbate this the
situation so putting the onus on the
individual and not requiring it this is
New Hampshire we're not going to require
an individual to have to identify if
they don't want to it's optional but for
those that would and and will it will
help the system
um and you wouldn't know about in in to
your point the Fail-Safe until an
individual wanted to then make a request
so if everything was going fine then the
information would just get entered and
it would go according to how it went and
it would be audited by the department
periodically uh when they do their
audits but if the individual who was
part of an interaction with law
enforcement felt in some type of way
that hey this interaction was not the
way that I feel it should have gone in
sense of you know how I feel uh treated
and respected they could then request
that information publicly which is
allowed by law and then that information
would be there to accompany and then
could lead to research and Analysis
follow-up follow-up
so
so it seems to me that there is no data
right now you can't tell
whether
if there's no ethnicity data or racial
data on the license in the database you
don't know that
um
their racer ethnicity was misreported
as part of a traffic stop you don't know
if that was intentional to try to
avoid any kind of conflicts or to show
any kind of racial profiling because you
don't have the data it doesn't exist so
in order to to create that and to show
whether things are going really well or
you know there is some profiling or
where the problems are that's why you
need this
actually
another question I'm just I'm trying to
get to the question is that why you need
this extra piece
uh
so if I understand correctly this this
in this data collection is necessary to
ensure that we it's not currently in
entirety the state police are doing a
great job right now on putting this out
there but it's not uniform across the
state you have other departments you
have uh the Hollis Police Department
other Kalia departments that have data
but not all police departments which
then leads to issues when you're trying
to analyze the system so having this
requirement would then make that data
available publicly to everyone and
because federally it's already being
required of certain departments
representative Sykes
I I just want to make sure I understand
this correctly so
the attempt the purpose of this bill is
to improve upon data collection
and make it more universally collected
because not all communities are doing so
at this time
that is part of the con that is part of
the intent of this yes correct and one
more follow-up if I may yeah follow it
and I just I thought I heard you say
earlier
that the federal government now requires
this but it's not happening everywhere
in New Hampshire did I mishear that
because I don't honestly don't have my
hearing aids in today so I want to make
sure I heard that right so so nybers is
a system it's the national
um the national incident uh
I forgot what the H's reporting system
and what it does is it uh I'll have to
look at what the H is it collects data
uh that is reported by the state police
involving crime statistics in New
Hampshire
part of the demographics uh that is
collected is uh race and ethnicity and
if this is but that is what they're
required to do now the state police will
then
go uh ask the local departments to
report that data to them right not all
departments are doing it and that is
where it goes
Rumbo
thank you Mr chair
um did I understand correctly sorry if
you need a moment um that it would be
the race and ethnicity information will
be recorded as a as a code number or
something along those as opposed to
term did I hear someone say that on
license or would just be
listed as a race or ethnicity would it
be numerical code yeah so I I don't I
don't think that we would I I wouldn't I
wouldn't Envision something that just
says black on you know my license uh to
identify as that uh or you know but yeah
it would be an alphanumeric
um system that would be kept at the
division of motor vehicles and then that
would be internal code and then one when
an officer would have a license it would
just Auto populate on the report of
their interaction okay I guess I was
wondering if an officer pulls you over
and asks your license and looks at your
license he or she
see the alphanumeric code
and perhaps be able to more accurately
reflect in their report also as opposed
to perhaps a misunderstanding or you
know misapprehension
um correct in addition to the Fail-Safe
that we were talking about a double
checking later oh correct and and in
actuality most officers probably won't
even know what that alphanumeric code
stands for what they if they you know
identify list because it wouldn't just
be limited to the certain things um we
heard earlier for Eva Costello about
ethnicity and ethnicities there's uh
nuances to them so having
um a flushed out system would would be
helpful
okay thank you
okay keep in mind this is the ACLU we
have other people speaking that may be
better for the technical aspects of the
bill by all means representative thank
you
um and thank you for taking my question
I'm a new legislator and I am not um
familiar with react
um I knew that it existed
um but um could you briefly characterize
the type of testimony that led to the
conclusions arrived at by the report
that this kind of data collection was
necessary did you have public testimony
thank you
do I have a public testimony by the liac
commission
um information gathering part of
Gathering part of the um of the
commission's work did you have public
testimony from people that led you to
believe that this type of data
collection was necessary yes yes we did
okay thank you that's all that answered
that question required so any other
questions from the committee
scene and thank you very much
I have two cards from the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
did you want to go individually or did
you want to to do it jointly your call
okay uh Joseph habecki from Hollis
Police Department and Charles Reynolds
from Dover
both in support of the bill uh each
looking for about three minutes for
Testimony
good morning
all right we're good sorry let me
started uh good morning and Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Joseph hobecki and I'm the chief of
police in Hollis New Hampshire I'm also
the immediate past president of the New
Hampshire Association the chiefs of
police I'm joined here today sir
bye oh sorry
um my name is Charles Reynolds I'm the
former police chief in Dover also past
president of New Hampshire Chiefs many
many years ago however and uh just as an
aside at one time was a member of the
House a regulated Revenue Committee in
1995-96
um
so I I join you here this morning in
support of host pill 597. I did want to
just uh make some comments and and maybe
some recommendations uh but I'll I'll
first start with a little bit of a his
uh history with my involvement
um obviously this recommendation was uh
the basis or one of the recommendations
from the liac Commission
in the uh immediate aftermath of the
liac recommendations I was involved with
the legislative work group that worked
on this very Bill and I've testified
that on this and on a number of
occasions and my my goal has always been
to inform legislators and stakeholders
about some of the realities that we deal
with in terms of uh data collection in
specifically uh police records
Management Systems
um I I'm a chief of an accredited agency
so uh we are required to provide a
review of
bias-based policing to identify any
negative Trends and if there are
negative Trends to make the appropriate
modifications and corrections but I will
tell you that in terms of Records
Management systems
that I would hope that all agencies in
the state utilize electronic records
Management Systems used there are
varying levels of ability in terms of
extrapolating data and then using that
data to generate these reports and these
reviews so that it's reliable and it
provides the reviewer with valuable
information on how the police are doing
in terms of biospace policing
uh there's also naturally a very uh
there's a financial cost to these
efforts
um so I I do think we need to be mindful
of that in terms of the legislation
aside from what's indicated for the
modifications to the DMV vision system
um I would also ask if if you look at uh
line eight on page one
um you know when I look at legislation
as a chief I oftentimes ask myself what
is the usefulness
uh and certainly ask that question in
terms of motor vehicle accident and
fatality information
um
I'm not sure what the intent or
usefulness of that specific data point
is from my understanding I think that
might be a new addition from previous
versions of the bill I could be wrong
but I'm just curious uh as to what the
intent is there for and and again I ask
myself the questions of usefulness
because I do believe it adds a layer of
complexity uh to a process of data
collection that is already very complex
um
I would also be remiss and I mentioned
it before that I work for an accredited
agency I'm lucky
um and that that's a national accredited
accrediting body independent body and
there are specific standards uh
two data collection or the provision of
review of data as it relates to
demographics and such I won't get into
the specific standard numbers but I have
some testimony that I'll hand out
that has those standards attached to it
additionally as you may or may not be
aware New Hampshire has created uh just
most recently a state accreditation
program and I can tell you because I'm
on the commission that there will be a
standard relative to biospace review and
Analysis of information
um lastly there's recommendations that
are in draft form from the Department of
Justice in terms of accreditation
standards in what independent
accrediting bodies should look for and
this also is an additional component of
that as well and it names uh
specifically detention such as stops
frisks searches summonses and arrests
I just wanna
reiterate the fact that in order for
this information to be useful it has to
be collected into standardized and
systematic manner there are states
around us who do that and I can think of
Vermont and they have struggled since
its Inception uh with the statute to
collect this data in a reliable
standardized systematic way
um so it's not just setting up a system
it's about having a good system in place
because data without uh a reliable means
to collect it and populate
is not going to be reliable it's just
going to be
data that isn't sufficiently supported
and I'm no mathematician or scientist
but
um that's that's not an accepted way to
do business
so
um those are my thoughts I'd be happy to
answer any questions I Know Chief
Reynolds has uh some commentary as well
yep bullet Chief Reynolds go first and
we'll open it up to questions thank you
well thank you Mr chair
um
my interest uh in this comes from the
past several years I've been involved
with uh federal court audit monitoring
of police departments
dealing with civil rights
which has included the review and
Analysis of data relating to police
interactions
for example one of the cities that I
worked with my duties were to analyze
twenty thousand stops on an annual basis
so get an Insight on the data that's
needed to do that effectively
first a couple of points first in order
for demographic data to be of value it
must be accurate therefore absent the
inclusion of the requested demographic
data on individuals driver's license or
other recognized identification
the recording of such data relies on two
things first asking for the information
by the officer or
recording his or her perception of the
person's race gender or other
demographic data neither of which are
recommended practices
decisions must also be made regarding
the identification of Pop various
populations groups both race and ethnic
will our identification be consistent
with the OMB directive 17 or within New
Hampshire
census population data questions that
need to be answered moreover in addition
to collection of Motor Vehicles stop
data
suggested in this bill a meaningful
analysis of data relating to the
interaction
the interaction between the officer and
the individual
should include whether or not there was
a search whether the Search is with or
without the consent whether or not
Contraband was seized or not these are
all important data Concepts if we want
to understand whether or not this was a
legitimate police interaction or was it
racially biased
the point is for this effort we need to
have a comprehensive meaningful and
thoughtful process
law enforcement agencies in New
Hampshire particularly the smaller ones
which are comprise some majority as you
know do not presently have the
analytical capacity to do so
nor are they likely to locally acquire
the result the funds to purchase or
modify their Data Systems
to be able to accomplish the
comprehensive data collection effort so
clearly this will require an investment
in data analysis capability for our
various law enforcement agencies and
therefore the 108 000 fiscal note on
this bill
appears to be inadequate
finally I just make this comment
I frequently seize news see news
accounts reporting on police encounters
alleging the police are
disproportionately interacting with
specified minority communities and note
that while the data the data presented
on its face is accurate
it really portrays an inaccurate
activity on part of the police to expect
interactions between the police and each
specific race ethnic agenda will be
proportional to census data is simply
unrealistic accordingly a thoughtful and
thorough approach is required in perhaps
this leads us to that
and with that I I hope you will give
this bill some serious consideration and
be pleased to answer any questions you
may have
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I guess this is kind of to both
of you
let's say that this bill was placed in
was placed uh was passed
how often would you be reviewing this
data
sure
um
I think at least annually I think we're
required to do that annually and provide
a review of of the data
um I think that's probably the best
answer I can give you I don't know
Charlie if you have any additional
commentaries sir well in some of the
places where I work at are a significant
size but what we would do is look at the
data on a monthly basis to try to
determine if there were some trends of
concerns so we didn't wait until the end
of the year to decide if we had to do
some interaction but if we look if it
looked like there was some aberration in
the data we would be able to drill down
and and determine whether or not it was
profiling or incorrect activities on the
plot of police and take corrective
action
follow up follow up thank you Mr
chairman so
let's say that you took a look at this
and you saw some trends
do you talk to the entire force or do
you go down to a police officer or two
in regards to trends that you're seeing
well uh
that varies a little bit the agencies I
worked in were
had significant data and and when we saw
an aberration we would uh take that we
were able to take that right down to the
supervisor in the squad
and the individual officer to determine
whether or not uh there was some issues
of concern for instance one time we had
just tell you the story one time we had
a concern it seemed like there was a
spike in interactions with Asians
so we tracked that down and we found out
the squad that was responsible for that
was actually a sign to work Asian gangs
so you know we were able to identify
quickly why that Spike was there there
are other examples but that that was
always one that
sort of amazed us when we got there so
this was explainable but in a smaller
scale uh I think Chief ovecki can bet
her answer better answer that but that
data
when you look at it you see those
aberrations pretty quickly if it's if
it's collected completely and accurately
representative Coker
thank you Mr chairman so just uh out of
curiosity do you have like a round
number that it would cost to upgrade the
data infrastructure for like a small
normal
I don't
um give you an idea our records
management system
we have 18 officers 21 employees
it costs 16 to 17 000 a year and uh
annually you can factor in and increase
roughly five to seven percent each year
um that's one feature included within
the software
um
you know in and then you have the issue
of the data you know extracting the data
in a format that's that's easy to
interpret and then populate into a
review I know our records management uh
system IMC which is quite common in the
state many agencies use it you can run a
data point one way and then run it at
you know what you think is the same way
and get two different data points
and and so you have to be very careful
with the data you you're you're trying
to run and analyze because you want to
make sure it's accurate as accurate as
you can be
um
Oh by answering your question follow-up
so another question I had is um for the
uh Kayla certification
um the information you gather on that
the demographic information is that
based you can get certification just
based on the officer's perception or how
does that you are you familiar with how
that works I am excuse me I am let me
read the standard applicable standard
it's consistent between both the
national and state programs and it says
a documented annual administrative
review of agency practices including
citizen concerns and any corrective
measures and then it talks about within
the commentary
um reviewing uh this this data for our
officers it's based on their perception
I'm not going to require an officer to
ask on a motor vehicle stop or roadside
how a person
you know what race or ethnicity I don't
think that's appropriate and the last
thing we want to do is cause further
divisions within communities of colors
because we're asking these questions
it's not it's just not good practice and
many of the stakeholders that are
sitting behind us agree to that it's
just it's not the right way to do
business
thank you I appreciate it and just a
follow-up
um some of the previous testimony
indicates that
the demographics were misrepresented on
reports and when you leave that to the
office's perception oftentimes that can
occur because let's face it there are a
lot of people at a mixed race a lot of
people that can be mistaken for one or
the other
they can be a lot of errors and then to
leave it to accuse the officer of making
uh
intended misrepresentation is unfair
thank you seeing no other questions
thank you both very much thank you Mr
chair
okay
okay uh we have two more people signed
up to testify they're both asking for
five minutes
that's perfect timing so I'm going to
hold you to the five minutes uh next up
is James
I see
mckayer from the Kim sorry about that
from the NAACP in support of the bill
seeking five minutes good morning
thank you
good morning Mr chair and and uh
committee members
uh my name is James McKim I have a
number of roles that are related to this
uh this bill and this topic uh one I am
managing partner for organizational
ignition which is a management
consulting practice where I help
organizations to improve their sense of
belonging and culture and performance
through diversity equity and inclusion
I also serve as president of the
Manchester branch of the NAACP
and I served with pride on the law
enforcement
accountability community and
transparency commission the liact
commission
um that has been mentioned here before
we spent much time
discussing this very topic
I wholeheartedly support this bill
you've already heard
that this bill originated as a result of
many many discussions
with Lee act and hearings which the
governor gave us two months
to take testimony and to come up with
the 38 recommendations that we came up
with as a result of our efforts
many of the concerns about this bill
some mentioned here
have been raised by law enforcement and
we took the time to listen to those
concerns and craft legislation which we
all agreed addressed those concerns
so I would hope that you would trust the
logic of this bill that it is sound
and that the reasons not to collect
racial data both logical reasons and
emotional reasons have been overcome
I Rise before you to highlight
the fact that there is a lack of trust
of law enforcement
and the criminal justice system
which we feel having this data will help
address through increasing transparency
NAACP polling suggests that 87 percent
of black adults say that the U.S
criminal justice system
is more unjust toward black people
61 of whites adults agree
lest you think those statistics are not
relevant to New Hampshire
research from the sentencing project
shows that New Hampshire has a black
white imprisonment disparity ratio of
5.2 to 1.
and a hispanic white ratio of two to one
it's been suggested
that collecting this data is akin to
racial profiling
I would suggest to you that this is a
specious argument
first racial profiling happens when an
officer is in the field before someone
is pulled over not when data is being
collected
second we people of color would be the
first to make the claim that the bill
constituted racial profiling if we
thought it was
and we have not
in fact following the idea of author
James Baldwin
that not everything that is faced can be
changed but nothing that nothing can be
changed until it is faced we have
steadfastly asked for the collection of
this data
in recognition that the collection is
critical in facing racial profiling and
combating racial profiling
third the New Hampshire judicial branch
is initiated A diversity and inclusion
effort led by Chief Justice Gordon
McDonald
for which I serve as an advisor
recognizing the importance
of having this same data
in adjudicating cases
there is a specific subcommittee
working on collection of this very same
data as input to how to improve how
the justice system serves people of
color
in conclusion please do not make this a
political discussion
please pass this bill so that the entire
criminal justice system can uphold the
last sentence of Article 2 of the New
Hampshire Constitution Bill of Rights
which reads a quality of rights under
the law shall not be denied or Abridged
by this state on account of race Creed
color sex or national origin
thank you for your time I'm happy to
entertain any questions you might have
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
then thank you again
thank you
next up chair recognizes
Matthew broadland or Brad Leed
um in support of the bill from
representing the New Hampshire
Department of Justice seeking five
minutes
thank you Mr chairman thank you Matt
Broadhead on behalf of the New Hampshire
Department of Justice and I'm here today
on behalf of Attorney General John from
Ella who apologizes that he couldn't be
here today but we support this bill this
is with that I don't want to be
repetitive so this is a product of the
leeact commission recommendation this
bill has been substantially in the same
form before the legislature and then
before a study committee for the better
part of two and a half years at this
point
um it does reflect what at the time was
a consensus between Community
stakeholders police unions police Chiefs
our office members from the community as
well
and uh and and I do understand that it
was sent to study for some concerns
but nobody has come forward with any
sort of alternative Vision so here we
are and we do support the bill I did
want to walk you through just the
general there's three broad Strokes in
terms of what this build does the first
section of the bill exempts certain data
from the driver privacy act as you know
there's a default rule that any data
collected on a you know in the course of
uh Motor Vehicle Record including data
that's on a driver's license is
generally exempt from public disclosure
this first section creates an exemption
to that
the the second broad stroke are sections
two three four five six and seven and
eight which amend the various types of
licenses there are three types of
non-drivers IDs one just a regular run
of the mill driver ID than a real ID and
then the Enhanced Driver's ID which
also provides for proof of citizenship
as you all know and then this it does
the same thing for driver's licenses and
commercial driver's licenses the third
section is section nine which uh is in a
new statute that's immediately placed
after a current statute which requires
certain information
uh to be in a arrest record including
the identity of the person that's being
arrested the way we view this is that
this is no different than a pre-existing
law that it just acts to clarify what
that pre-existing law that requires
information to be contained in the
arrest record
and it was said before and it Bears
emphasizing now
um all that's needed is a scan of a
license in order to pre-populate this
data and what this does would uh by
adding ethnicity and and race to as one
of the data points that's collected
albeit optional
um that it would also be pre-populated
once the an officer pulls somebody over
brings the license and registration
backs back to their Cruiser scans the
license just like it pre-populates right
now in the majority of jurisdictions
both local and all of State Police it
pre-populates their their name
address and other information that's
contained on the driver's license and it
would also Auto populate race and
ethnicity in that respect uh so it it
does eliminate uh the testimony before
the layout commission was that officers
uh reasonably are uncomfortable making
judgment calls right now there is in our
uh it's a non-mandatory field as part of
the neighbors National incident based
Reporting System that's a federal system
uh or it's a it's a it's a state system
that reports to the federal government
through a U.S doj Grant
which we do participate in in State
Police administers
that that information is contained in
some of those uh incident-based arrests
what happens under current law is that
it's since it's a non-mandatory field
it's sparsely populated sometimes
they're filled out sometimes they're not
even Within State Police it's
inconsistent from a uh from that
perspective so what this does is it
enables those communities who were to be
uh you know who would like to seek Kalia
certification which is as others had
said that gold standard it allows a
better source of data
the
um I I will leave it at that and I'm
happy to answer any questions we do
strongly support and urge the committee
to pass the bill as written
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you sir questions from the
committee
representative coca thank you Mr
chairman do you have any data from the
states where uh where it's optional like
that have a similar Bill like what the
opt-out rate is I don't okay I don't and
I don't know that the committee took
testimony
um to do to to that effect the
commission the governor's commission
um so I'm sorry I don't have to answer
that all right thank you
I just got one question and to summarize
I or hopefully I understood what you
said
you
do you believe that the option which
basically this whole bill is consisting
of
is probably not perfect but it's the
best thing we could come up with and
nobody else could come up with anything
better is that what you said we're
alluded to yes well thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh next up chair recognizes major Joseph
Ebert from the state police uh not
taking
I guess not taking a position on the
bill at this point looking for three
minutes
good afternoon now good afternoon uh I
am Joseph Ebert it's eb-e-r-t I am a
major with the state police I oversee
the Investigative Services Bureau which
is your state police detectives I'm also
very aware that my testimony May stand
between you and lunch so I will keep
this very brief uh
I guess I one of the things I noticed
when reading the uh this year's version
of this legislation is there is the
inclusion of the ZIP code or identifying
where the individual is from New
Hampshire is somewhat a transitory State
and by that I mean there are lots of
people who are stopped on our roadways
who are interactive with law enforcement
who come from outside of the State of
New Hampshire so I think it's uh that
portion uh that addition to this bill
was very important however I noticed in
the uh the uh the back portion of this
which is uh page three where it talks
about the aggregate data that shall be
reported uh if the bill were to go
forward I would like to see on behalf of
the State Police we'd like to see the
the ZIP code inclusion in there as well
as data that shall be reported uh police
standards and training
I I will not uh uh bemoan the uh the
fact that I think has already been uh
addressed which is if if you put
inaccurate data into a system you can
expect that inaccurate data comes out of
it uh what I will say though is that
um we are certainly uh uh well aware of
the need for accurate data what that has
at least in previous iterations of the
bill would that has been referred to as
how do you credential a person's race or
ethnicity I I don't know and I don't sit
before you uh and pretend to know the
answer to that question
um we are absolutely as an organization
the state police is absolutely in uh
support of the Lee act recommendations
and that's not a throwaway line we are
truly in support of that and we want to
grow our relationships with all
communities within the state we also
want to make sure that we do not cause
divides by producing inaccurate data and
by that I mean it it will analyzing data
where somebody is not required on the
front end everyone required to be in one
subset would allow for
data to be output never knowing or never
being able to understand how many people
opted out of the ability to add their
race to their driver's license
I think there's an ancillary issue that
may uh occur that's kind of unique to
New Hampshire in that what what happens
and this was uh brought up in a previous
testimony but what happens when an
individual comes into the DMV is clearly
uh an African-American or clearly a
Caucasian and puts on their form the
opposite uh that's compounded further by
the fact that in New Hampshire you can
put X as a gender
so you now have somebody who could put
x's agender and identify inappropriately
as their uh as their race this is
further compounded uh when you look at
the notion that you can have your photo
expunged from the DMV system by request
so I I just I bring that uh to your
attention because I think it's uh as an
end user or at some point in my career I
was an end user of somebody sitting on
the side of the road trying to identify
an individual it becomes markedly more
difficult when the data that you're
provided is not consistent and not
required for everyone across the board
um
I think the the last thing I would leave
you with is that uh we are keenly aware
uh of the perceptions by certain
communities within our state and we want
to work to improve any of those uh that
don't have a positive review of law
enforcement
I'd also put forward to you that I think
there is a concern on the part of law
enforcement that data that is inaccurate
would be posted to a website and made
public and judgments would be made on
the part of the public that may be
incongruent with fact in other words
somebody May read the data and not dig
in enough to know that there isn't the
option to opt out they may not dig in
enough to know and understand the data
that is being presented to them and that
may cause a divide so we are certainly
in favor of the concept of this law we
just have current concerns with the
current stat status of it and how it
came to be so I I hope I address that I
hope I address uh that in a coherent
manner if I haven't I'm available for
any questions and I thank the committee
very much for the time this morning
thank you very much
um any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you again thank you
all very much
director marasco from the New Hampshire
Department of Motor Vehicles no position
looking for one minute you're the best
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
um if this bill were to pass I just
wanted to let you know that from a DMV
standpoint this is something that we
would be able to implement uh with
regards to uh from a cost standpoint
there was a previous LSR that was
generated for I believe a previous bill
that was around a hundred thousand
dollars and it appears as though it
would still come in at that same uh
General threshold so from a cost
standpoint we could we would find a way
to make it work and um as far as if it
did go on the credential itself there is
an enva international standard on the
amount of information that can be on a
driver's license but if we're talking
about a number or some small indicator
we can find a way to do that so I just
want to share that thank you
thank you director any questions from
the committee
you he answered your example
yep yep seeing none thank you very much
thanks uh with nobody else signed up to
speak I'm going to close the public
hearing on
house bill 597.
uh our next bill to be heard one o'clock
House Bill 650. see you then
all right good afternoon everybody being
104. I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 650 FN
um chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative tolerski welcome home I
mean welcome back
thank you Mr chairman
it's nice to be back
although briefly
for those of you who don't know me my
name is Laura talerski I represent
nashua's War date which is Hillsborough
11 and I served my last two terms here
on this committee
today I'm here to present House Bill 650
FN relative to prohibiting suspension of
driver's licenses due to non-payment of
fines or fees
house Transportation has seen this bill
before but for the newer members I'll
start by setting up this simple scenario
a person finds themselves in a situation
where they have a fine and for whatever
reason times may be tough they are a
hard-working parent trying to keep their
family going or it's someone trying to
get on their feet whatever the situation
could be they just can't pull together
the extra money the court then says okay
you haven't paid you're fine we're going
to have to punish you now by taking away
your driver's license so now our person
who's barely getting by and trying to
make ends meet has no transportation to
get to work where they may actually
stand a chance of earning the money they
need to pay back the fine or fee in the
first place there's now a downward
spiral with a compounding problem that
puts this person even further behind and
unable to get on their feet let's say
they somehow find a way to earn the
money to pay their fee even though they
have no way to get to work and now they
can get their license reinstated but
guess what there's yet another fee to
get their license back
debt related driving restrictions can
cost people their livelihoods leaving
them unable to get to work and be
positive contributors to society
licensed suspension for non-payment of
fines fees or restitution
disproportionately punishes the poor
this bill has been through house
Transportation twice in recent history
in 2020 House Bill 1667 was a bipartisan
Bill sponsored by representative David
Welch that was viewed as overly broad
this committee worked together to amend
the bill very similar to the draft that
you have before you today and it passed
this committee 20 to nothing and was put
on the consent calendar before dying due
to covid
in 2021 it was filed again as House Bill
435 and was retained by this committee
there were some last minute concerns
that came up and in the end we passed a
version that would remove the director's
ability to suspend a license due to
moral turpitude which was signed into
law
so once again here we are back to try
and Tackle prohibition of licenses
suspensions for non-payment of fines
fees and restitution I want to be clear
that taking away a license should be
used when there is a direct threat to
Public Safety on the roads but
suspending a license for non-payment of
fines can very simply make it harder for
people to pay it doesn't push them to
pay if they can't pay in the first place
another scenario two people receive
speeding tickets with fines and fees one
pays and continues driving no change in
their behavior the other can't afford to
pay and their license is suspended the
suspension is solely about money it's
not about public safety and the rich
person can continues to drive with a
different punishment than the poor
person
dealing with the courts police or the
DMV successfully should not be different
for the poor and the rich
everyone here knows that New Hampshire
is quite Rural and lacks adequate public
transportation options leaving a person
with few choices when needing to get to
work buy food get kids to school or
Access Health Care with few options a
person may risk driving with a suspended
license opening themselves up to even
more complicated legal issues if they're
stopped it's like a snowball that keeps
getting bigger because they are poor and
desperate to work and provide for their
family
a few quick things about the bill in
front of you on line 10 part B
this carves out the exception that a
license can be suspended for failure to
pay child support
this was brought up the first time we
saw this bill it is a federal
requirement so that can still occur
the sections that follow on page one
don't change anything in existing law
they're just being re-lettered
on page two
there is a new section Roman 8.
it was our intent here to Simply spell
it out
however we think this may not be needed
with the changes that we make made at
the start of the bill I suppose I can
leave that up to others who may be
testifying or for the committee to
address
some argue that suspension of licenses
Works to incentivize people in some way
but is a good policy to inflict pain and
hardship on the poor particularly when
the situation that brought them to that
place had absolutely nothing to do with
their driving behavior or their ability
to drive safely
lastly I would just like to address the
fiscal note that details that the DMV
could lose four million dollars a year
in revenue from restoration fees if this
bill passes
I would ask what the priority here
should be should the state be relying on
Revenue primarily coming from the poor
we need to think about the economic
impact of these people keeping their
license being able to work make money
and spend money in our state and I would
guess that the impact to our state is
significantly greater than a hundred
dollar reinstatement fee being paid to
the DMV
I'll finish because I know there were
other people who want to testify but I
thank you very much for taking my
testimony today
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair
thank you in this
this is probably going to be a crazy
question but
I'm thinking that
you know if I if I'm speeding and I I
don't have to pay the bill because of
because you don't have to pay it
um maybe the third or fourth time I
still I'm still not paying it can you
think of any any uh
reason that or something that could be
done not because somebody's income but
if somebody is constantly uh doing a
traffic violation that potentially could
cause bodily harm rather speeding or
whatever that could be uh done to uh
somehow maybe take the license away for
a certain amount of time with the fine
notwithstanding something along those
lines
thanks
thank you for the question
um two things come to mind to answer
that question one is the data I've seen
is pardon me is that those who can
afford to pay actually do pay
and then they go on with their lives and
keep driving there are really uh there's
little evidence that people who have the
ability to pay just don't because they
don't think there will be any
ramifications
also I have a fact sheet here in front
of me which I think you might get some
information uh after me
um
but they they can still have their
license suspended if they are a habitual
offender if they go to that next level
of negligent driving
what are the questions
representative Style
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question in Section 8 it says
the license uh shall not be suspended
due to non-payment of fines or
restitution how do you define
restitution what does that mean thank
you
thank you for the question actually
um what flag to this section is we need
to fix it is it also should say if we
keep it finds fees and restitution
um it's restitution uh to the courts
any further questions representative
sellers
thank you Mr chair
so if someone gets a ticket today
and they just don't pay it they're not
habitual they just don't pay it
how how do we go about the
disciplining them if you want to say
is there anything in this law that would
help that
if they are if they don't respond
um they
could be considered a habitual offender
and they uh person who fails to appear
could have a bench warrant issued for
their arrest
and they could subsequently
um
if they encounter the police be dealt
with in that manner
do you want to follow
so basically you're saying that they
have to at some point respond and pay
that fine yeah I have another note here
forgive me I had a whole lot of
information coming into this that if the
person does not pay a fine
um it explicitly allows the court to
notify that non-payer that a hearing can
be scheduled at which the court will
decide if they actually have the ability
to pay the fine
so if they do have the ability if the
court determines they have the ability
to pay the fine and then they do not pay
then they can be jailed at a rate of 150
a day so there are other options that
the court has
any further questions
representative C
uh thank you Mr chairman on this um
uh online page one line five where it
talks about this is in conjunction with
uh motor vehicle offense unless
otherwise allowed under law do you have
any idea what might be considered under
uh otherwise under the law
okay
I may defer to the people who helped me
draft the uh
the bill
for explicitly what they were referring
to with that
thank you I'm assuming it sorry I don't
interrupt you but I'm also assuming it
could refer to other statutes that uh
state that the suspension would be
allowed which is I don't know if the top
of my head but it's where it lists all
the uh the different times when it is
allowable to suspend a license
what are the questions representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh representative solorski for
taking my question
um on Section 8 on the on line 17.
we where it says uh comply with a
sentencing order that's imposed a duty
to pay fines fees or restitutions in a
criminal case
this section looks like it's uh sorry
can you just tell me where you're
looking uh second page
uh line 17
okay says fees or restitutions in a
criminal case
so it looks like this section's about
allowing
things to be expunged from the records
so a criminal case are we talking a
motor vehicle violation or
s our criminal case situation
thank you for the question
I believe it has to do with if the
license was suspended
due to another uh situation not the
fines or fees but to a criminal case
um that it would be expunged
but I would want clarification if that
if that is a broad
um reference to all criminal cases I
don't I didn't believe so okay thank you
I may be reading it wrong though
if it helps keep your questions we have
somebody later on that may be able to
answer them more specifically any other
questions from the committee
seeing none I've got six just kidding
thank you again
I thought you'd go hard on me chairman
but thank you for your time
um next up chair recognizes
after being here all day you're moving
up in the ranks Eva Castillo
representing herself in support of the
bill looking for a minute
um I am in support we are in support of
this bill I'd still need to introduce
yourself again Castillo I live in
Manchester
um I'm a community advocate we all know
that everything has gone up the cost of
everything the cost of living in
Manchester we have a horrendous
situation with rent and uh like people
don't know where to live and their rents
are going through the sky the services
have got have doubled up electricity
Ford everything has gone up so you know
to to penalize somebody for not paying a
fine these people are going to have to
choose between paying a fine or feeding
their children or paying their for their
medication or paying for the Heat or
paying for something so who do you think
they're gonna they're gonna choose so
this will carry catastrophic
consequences for someone to lose their
license they like we talked this morning
they need licenses to go to work they
need their licenses to to go about their
daily living to go to the doctors to do
so many things so this this is a bad
punishment for not only for poor people
also for a lot of the new Americans that
have the low paying jobs that take care
of our community uh in so many ways that
we take for granted but we don't
recognize so please take into
consideration the consequences of
passing a bill like this on a purely
economic thing thank you
thank you very much any questions from
the community
seeing none I
next up I do apologize it is customary
to let our other Representatives
go first so they can go about their
business uh chair recognizes
representative Lucas
uh in support of the bill
thank you uh chairman of the committee
um
Tony lekkis I represent Hillsboro 38 the
towns of Hudson and Litchfield I handed
out some written testimony I'm not going
to read it
um
first of all I agree completely with
what's been said before
I mean while revoking a person's
driver's license may be an effective way
to coerce somebody who's got the money
to pay
it can create a you know a real
Injustice to people that can't pay
there is a provision as I understand it
and current law that if someone can't
pay their license won't be suspended but
the problem there is you have to
proactively you know go to the court to
arrange that and the people who have the
most problems here
are they're not going to have somebody
representing them in most cases they're
they're not going to be aware of the law
they don't know how to work the system
um and and basically that provision I
think in most cases is ineffective
um as the part of speaker said
you know with the change they could then
later be brought back in to deal with
that particular issue where you know
that's then presented and they don't
have to bring it up first and uh you
know they can present their situation
which I think is a better situation I
you know the testimony of the public
hearing is for people to learn things uh
that occurred for me here I was unaware
that there was an exception for child
support and that there was a federal
requirement around that I included a
personal story of my extended family of
somebody ran into problem with this but
it did have to do with child support So
this bill would not help but
um the similar kind of things can happen
for things other than child support you
know somebody has
a situation where you know somebody's a
kind of low-level contractor doing
siding windows that sort of thing
their income is uh you know very
seasonal uh very irregular and in this
case
um this person was able to pay extra
when he had money come in and couldn't
pay later when he couldn't and because
that payment had to go directly to the
state they ended up taking his license
um during a you know off season and then
he was very difficult to go to work I
mean you can't you know take an Uber if
you got to move your work truck you got
to find somebody who could drive it and
uh it you know he was able to actually
um was less able to pay his obligations
as a result of that
um
and I mean I I've heard I don't know you
know the position of anyone in the
committee but I've heard from others
that you know people that don't pay
Their fines their you know scoff laws
and they don't have much sympathy for
them but if you have somebody who's in a
very difficult financial situation and
they're barely getting by
um I don't think it makes any sense to
remove their ability to drive legally
because what's going to happen is out of
desperation they're likely to end up
driving illegally and then if they get
caught doing that they're further meshed
in the criminal justice system further
costs
um and just a spiral into a real mess
and that's where people that are just
barely getting by as it is and I just
don't think it's a Justice to do that to
them and in some cases out of
desperation may end up resorting to
Crime just to support themselves and
their family and I don't think that's
what they want
um so I see this bill as a practical
response to the situation
um and and just I think a good
government thing so that's all I have to
say thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
see you then thanks again thank you
uh chair recognizes Lily Jackson
representing the ACLU in support of the
bill does have written testimony and is
seeking four minutes to speak welcome
good afternoon committee members my name
is Lily Jackson and I'm here on behalf
of the ACLU testifying and support of HP
in New Hampshire driver's license can be
suspended for failure to pay court fines
and fees even if individuals too poor to
pay these fines and fees
once suspended an individual will have
to fulfill the requirements attached to
the suspension pay an additional
reinstatement fee and possibly have to
retake their driver's license exam if
the individual's license has suspended
for three or more years to clarify
addressing a suspension of a driver's
license for unpaid court fines and fees
would have no impact on the state's
ability to spend driver's license for
failure to take child support further to
fulfill requirements by sentence or
failure to appear when ordered to do so
it would also not impact driver's
license suspensions are part of a
traffic or criminal violation
wealth-based driver's license
suspensions punish people simply because
they are poor suspensions do not improve
the outcome of debt Collections and
there is growing evidence that
eliminating suspensions for non-payment
can save jurisdictions money and
maintain or even increase compliance
rates
since fines and fees are primarily on
those who cannot afford them the
collection rates of these debts are
usually frequently low
wealth-based driver's license
suspensions also have no Public Safety
justification and place unnecessary
hurdles in front of people seeking to
support their families
about driver's license is vital for
accessing Basics like employment
doctor's office and bank accounts the
importance of this license is even
greater in New Hampshire because the
state and the majority of its localities
lack basic public transportation
infrastructure
thus this place people in the impossible
position choose to drive illegally and
risk incarceration and more fines in
order to get to work and meet personal
or family needs or choose not to drive
and lose needed income and access to
education and other services
these suspensions have no Financial
justification while the proponents of
wealth-based driver's license
suspensions argue that they are
necessary to ensure payments of
outstanding Court debts research shows
that this is not true and cities where
debt-based sanction was reformed there
has been no negative impact on the
collection of fines
this follows common sense as people
without the ability to access public
transportation or reliable
transportation will will be unable to
earn money to pay back their Court debt
this also perpetuates New Hampshire's
two-tier justice system Equal justice
under law does not exist when a person
is punished determined by their wealth
rather than their actions
people who commit suction act face very
different punishments because of nothing
more than how much money they have in
their bank account for a person with
wealth a traffic ticket is nothing more
than a nuisance for a person without
wealth it can mean suspension of their
driver's license and this ensnares
people into the criminal justice system
they arrest more funds and fees and
entanglement to the justice system and
incarceration it is past time for
lawmakers to eliminate the law that only
serves to punish people and push
families further into poverty and
unnecessary contact with the criminal
legal system
in order to reduce the cyclical nature
of poverty and increase Public Safety
New Hampshire must end wealth-based
driver's license suspensions I urge this
committee to support HB 650 and end the
two-tier justice system
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
see you again thank you again thank you
oh next up also in support of the bill
Mikey Levis
seeking five minutes
welcome
hi my name is Mikey Levis I'm speaking
in support of the bill it's commonly
thought that driving is a privilege in
fact driving is a right in a lot of New
Hampshire it's very difficult to get
around if you don't have a car you can't
get to work you can't get to the grocery
store you could starve you could go on
welfare I don't think people want to
unnecessarily pay for a lot of these
things I've been without a car I'm
having car issues right now so in a
sense this speaks to me I've struggled
with this
this is about a fundamental right if
you're a Democrat this is a social
justice issue if you're a republican
think of it in the frame of gun rights
could you imagine if your gun rights
were suspended because you missed a
court date or you missed a fine
in fact this bill I think needs a few
amendments because it still allows if
you miss a court date they can still
suspend your license so then you're
going to have even more trouble
paying the fines once you are able to
get to court
I have missed court dates I did get it
corrected but it happens they send one
notice out and the mail can be issues
people move around there's all kinds of
problems with that so across the country
this is becoming an increasing issue
because people for the most part want to
pay their fi want to pay the fines and
if you can't drive to work
you can't earn that much I've worked in
restaurant Industries and half the
people there often are suspended for
child support or any number of other
things
speeding tickets any number of things
and
if they could get their license back
they'd be able to earn more
and subsequently pay the fines you have
to think about the single mother
who is struggling to get her kids to
school find someone to babysit get to
work they often have to
get friends or neighbors and that can be
difficult even with
people here there's a lack of density in
addition to lack of public
transportation there's often a lack of
people around
you also have to think of the young man
who's trying to get his life back
together and just wants to get
everything in order he's trying trying
real hard doesn't want to do drugs
doesn't want to fall into alcohol or
depression or suicide and
not being able to get to work and
earn a living can prevent you know can
cause a lot of problems
so these are the things we need to think
about it's really imperative that this
gets a 19 to zero not 18 to 1 not 17 to
two everyone has to be in agreement on
this this is a fundamental right that
people are able to get to their job or
where they need to go for their children
this is not going to affect if
somebody's a dangerous driver that's
fine we need other remediation things
for that but that's understandable but
just missing a court date or missing a
fine
that's just not acceptable because
the only way to pay your fine is if you
can work
the state claims that they'll lose
millions of dollars if this bill passes
that doesn't make any sense at all if
you can if you can get to work you can
pay your fines if you get if you can get
a better job you can earn more the state
will get more tax money this will
probably be a boon to the state revenue
because of that and to our friends in
law and law enforcement over there it
creates less friction with the community
when people aren't driving around
suspended people drive around suspended
all the time
and it creates a risk they take risks
and dangers and they might
make the wrong turn or something and put
people in danger if they're driving
legally
that won't happen and then there will be
more
or less friction with the law
enforcement community so they don't have
to worry every time they're stopping
someone that it's going to be a problem
so this is really in everyone's interest
there's no one who
who should really be opposing this bill
and
that's really
that's really all there is to it in my
view is just getting this done I know
Maine a few years ago did it other
states in the country are are trying to
pass this in similar bills there's court
cases circulating but it's been
difficult because there isn't really a
constitutional
clear thing about this but I would say
it's a cruel and unusual punishment to
stop to stop someone from being able to
get to work and get to the grocery store
because they didn't pay uh something as
simple as like a 50 or 70 dollar fine
so that's really just a
the
fundamental of it fundamentals of it and
the only reason it wasn't put in the
Bill of Rights is because back in the
1770s when the frame or 1780s excused me
when the framers were putting together
the Constitution it was totally
inconceivable
that
there would be law enforcement going
around and stopping people on their
horse carriages saying where's your you
know where's your valid horse carriage
license that's ridiculous so they didn't
even conceive of it they didn't even
conceive of the original Bill of Rights
they had to the more I guess radical
sectors had to say no we need these
rights so they if they had seen how
things turned out they probably would
have put some sort of right to
Transportation or right to
get around
so I think that was an unfortunate
oversight that we're dealing with but
it's really a fundamental thing
that we need to change so I am going to
I don't know the process for amending
I'm going to suggest like one or two
amendments like the court court
appearance thing
but
I will look into that but as it is this
is a good bill to start with thank you
thank you for that the prime sponsor is
right behind you if you have some ideas
you'd like to share with her any
questions from the committee
CNN thank you
uh chair recognizes looking for three
minutes of time in support of the bill
Ross Connolly from AFP New Hampshire
ah thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee just for the record my
name is Ross Connolly I'm the deputy
state director for Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire here to
voice our support for HB 650. uh I'll
try to be brief because there's been a
lot of the points talked about but
driving is obviously an a critically
important factor for every Granite
stator to get to work to pick up their
kids to access basic needs
driving a motor vehicle can be a
privilege however the use of driver's
license suspension should be much more
targeted than it is currently
um
this is a tool that's really necessary
when somebody is a a true habitual
offender on the roads and is a danger to
the public uh because of their actions
while driving uh suspending somebody's
uh license for non-driving related
issues uh obviously as as has been said
uh defeats the perfect purpose and often
results in the opposite consequence
since the person cannot get to work they
cannot pay the fine and they're stuck in
a cycle of where they're breaking the
law because they're operating on a
suspended license
these suspensions also hurt businesses
I'll point out by making it more
difficult for workers to get to and from
uh their jobs to provide for their
families uh and these are consequences
that are particularly Troublesome in a
state where we have an acute labor
shortage we want to make sure that that
we're working with workers and
especially with people who are not a
danger on the road that they should be
able to continue to operate a motor
vehicle on the road so removing Granite
status driving privileges guarantees a
set pack as a setback in payment
especially since the individual's
employment as I mentioned may be
affected so for these reasons we urge
the committee to to move this bill ought
to pass I'd be happy to take any
questions if there are any
thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much you're
getting off easy today thank you
uh next up she recognizes
Richard head from the judicial branch
uh looking for five minutes not taking a
position at this point that's correct um
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch we don't have a
position on on the bill we recognize
it's uh it involves a very complex
balancing of policies and we don't have
a position on the policy itself but we
did want to talk about how it is we use
this in the in in circumstances of
default and exactly what the process is
we have relatively few tools available
when somebody is not paying their fines
we try if a person is not able to pay
their Their fines in full we work out
payment plans if their circumstances
change and they tell us their
circumstances have changed we will
modify that that payment plan we do not
want people to get into default we work
with folks to get them to pay Their
fines in those instances where the fines
are not being paid
um a default notice goes out and that
goes to the Department of Safety the
department of safety then notifies the
individual license holder that they have
30 days to contact the court so it's not
we push a button their license is in
default
um and and that's the end of it
we want
individuals to come to the court to work
out a payment plan if they are unable to
pay we would ask that you know we want
them to notify us tell us they are
unable to pay they'll get in front of a
judge and that circumstance can be
explained to the judge the judge can
modify the order what
what this is is a tool for the courts
when there is a non-payment of a fine
the other options are
um
are essentially defined that that they
are in contempt of court there's an
order they're in contempt that has its
own series of consequences this is a
tool that essentially is a a notice you
are in in trouble you're violating a
court order and there is a balance in
policies as between the very important
policy issues that folks have discussed
we don't disagree with those we people
who have a license are in better
position if they retain those licenses
it's employment it's a social fabric it
has a whole lot of consequences
associated with losing that license we
are sensitive to that there's also a
respect for the courts of respect for
the law aspect of it also that is a
balancing consideration
so our only our only
input I think is to say that we have
very few tools available to us when a
person gets into this position of being
in default none of the solutions are
great
um but this does provide a mechanism for
notice opportunity to cure and uh and a
cure to occur the other option of uh of
the finding of contempt is not a great
option and the option of Simply doing
nothing saying okay you didn't pay the
fine don't pay it is also not a great
option in terms of respect for the court
respect for uh for justice so
we understand and appreciate that it is
a difficult process conflict but it is
from the from the judicial branches
perspective one tool a very few tools
that we have available and to take this
away
complicates the the Opera sort of the
options that are available to the court
with that with that I'll conclude my
comments but would be happy to answer
any questions
thank you sir representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir for
taking my question
um would it be accurate for me to say
that
whenever the process gets to a point
where it's an interaction between the
person who has the initial fine and
having to go to court in order to take
some of the resolution steps that you
identified that that is a much more
lengthy and much more costly procedure
thank you for the question and I
apologize I may not have understood
exactly which is the procedure that's
well let me let me rephrase it then
um what I was asking I wanted to make
sure that if I were to characterize the
process of a person who has their
license suspended and has not paid the
fine
that anytime that process further
devolves into more interaction with the
court system it is reasonable to presume
that it'll be more costly more time if
time costly in terms of time and money
certainly if if the default is
ultimately implemented and that person
then has as a result of that
consequences that that flow from that
that involves additional Court actions
and additional Court proceedings that's
correct
yeah follow up
would the justice and I now this is just
a genuine question
would the justice system
for
driving offenses Etc be more efficient
for the state and the judicial system if
we remove one of the least
the most one of the more minor
considerations
um I don't know how so truthfully I
don't know
how many sort of cases or fines we're
talking about to be able to sort of give
a scale of that so I I so I apologize I
just don't know the answer
any other questions from the committee
uh by representative Fox
thank you Mr chair I would be interested
to know
um what the response the number or the
success of response for a person
receiving a contempt order versus a
person receiving a threat of a license
suspension so thank you for the question
I don't I don't know the answer it's a
great question
um I don't have that data if I can if I
can get it I'll be happy to pass along I
suspect I I may not be able to get it
but I'll see if I can get that
if we discover through those numbers
that contempt a threat of contempt is
successful or more successful would that
change your opinion
no because
um it would you know it may be relative
the license is the more frequent
mechanism
um so
um it you know the circumstances would
drive which mechanism is used
um so the success or failure of one over
the other is is sort of
independent of each other I think
representative do you have a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question we we're testimony
that instead of a licensed suspension
that a bench warrant could be issued
what's the difference in procedure
between those two
um a bench warrant a failure to to
comply with a bench warrant has its own
consequences
um including criminal
um penalties so you know once you're
getting into contempt bench warrants
you're you're heading towards further
criminal proceedings
um the what we would perceive as the
license
suspension as being an administrative
process one which there is
an opportunity that's given with notice
and if the notice is followed no
consequences to the individual bench
warrant being issued has consequences at
that point
any other questions okay representative
Sykes
thank you Mr chairman for indulging me
with a uh one more question and thank
you sir for the same
um I'm curious to know if you can tell
me when the last time the judicial
system
as a matter of In-House work took a look
at the tools that they have in their
toolbox and Wade
the relative merits of the of the tools
that you have used or are not using
um it's fair question and similar I
think to the other question if I can if
I can get an answer to that I'd be happy
to I don't know as I say here today
fair enough thank you for the questions
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
can you give me just a sense from the
point where
let's say someone does sides not to pay
to the point just before they get we
start getting into the court system
how long is that time are we talking
weeks months
so we imparted I apologize for saying
this thank you for the question it
depends
um if they're sort of sometimes they're
paying some and and so it could prolong
sort of when you get to that point of
default so it really is when you get to
that point of default you've ignored a
notice from the court it could be
shortly after depending on what the what
the payment plan is that's been worked
out so if you're paying weekly monthly
you know that will trigger the notices
and then the subsequent default and then
once the default is issued a copy of
that gets sent to safety so I don't
think there's sort of a a pattern a
specific time frame that could that
would flow from it so essentially you
have the the initial order
um that that assuming it's an order that
came out of the Court
um
they're either paying it immediately or
they're setting up a payment plan that
payment plan sort of then dictates in
compliance with that payment plan then
dictates when they're no longer in
compliance when they get the notice and
then when ultimately the default is
issued
thank you
one more
thank you Mr chair
um if I were a person who was Levy
defined and discovered that my financial
situation has changed I'm not able to
pay or I'm not able I need to make
payments I would then have to petition
the court have a hearing in order to
modify uh the fine in order to make
those payments
so two parts thank you for the question
two parts to my answer if it's simply a
modification of the payment plan that
could be worked out through the clerk's
office if it's a change in the actual
fine that would be through a judge
reviewing it and and deciding whether or
not the fine order would be modified
based on circumstances
and that could happen in that 30-day
window
um so you know other questions thank you
very much sir thank you and I apologize
normally I would stay I have to head
over to Children family law for a
hearing that's just about to start thank
you again and any of that information if
you can find it would be appreciated
thank you thank you uh chair recognizes
uh representative Hines
uh also in support of the bill looking
for two minutes
thank you Mr chair Dan Hines
representing town of Belford and by way
of background on criminal defense lawyer
and one of the things I just want to
focus on is that people who go under
suspension for
um opera or people whose license going
to suspension often do not know
um so we've heard testimony that gets
mailed to them I've represented many
people where that mail did not arrive in
some circumstances they might not have
updated their address quick enough with
the DMB or in other circumstances the
mail just never arose
um it's sort of an endless thing where
if people one thing I see this common is
so if you get a minor traffic violation
such as speeding or Lane change or
something like that it's up to the
person on the ticket they have 30 days
they can send it to the DMV saying I
plead not guilty and at some point DMV
um slowly sent us to the court who
slowly sends it to people so it could be
like six months down the line
um people aren't really expecting court
date and then they get a court date for
who knows how far down the line
um so if people don't get that notice
they're not going to show up to court
for that they are going to get defaulted
they're going to get their license
suspended which that letter presumably
might go to an address that either they
don't get or sometimes people might not
get that for a various reasons and after
after suspension if someone's found
guilty has significant consequences last
I checked the DMV can further suspend
someone's license even once this is
cleared up there's default penalties Etc
and it's significant points on a license
and it's a major offense towards
habitual offender law so New Hampshire
takes three offenses to be habitual
offender which is very serious
consequences it's minimum one-year
license loss up to four years and if
someone already had two major offenses
in a five-year period this could be that
third triggering thing that could force
them lose their license for a year so
um I when I in the past was a wrap by
putting the bill it's required
suspension layers to go out by certified
mail the state opposed that because it
costs money
um and my other uh response I'll happy
happy take any questions uh response to
representative Fox's question I don't
think it's uniform throughout the courts
about the time payment so I do agree
generally the clerk will allow or set
time payments but in a case where a
court or clerk didn't really want me
doing that over the counter they have me
submit a motion that motion did have to
get approved by the judge sometimes it's
quick usually a state doesn't take
possession on it I haven't really seen
prosecutors checked people getting time
payment plans but some courses don't act
on those timely uh just because a lot of
courts they're just overwhelmed and
judges aren't there every day so
um I usually put in when it's due so the
court can kind of get some urgency but I
don't know that people representing
themselves do that so
um I do agree generally the clerk will
do it but I don't think it's a uniform
practice
thank you any questions from the
committee
CNN thank you very much
having no one else to speak on House
Bill 650 I want to close the public
hearing
next up we
will be hearing House Bill 388 at one
30.
which I guess we're on our way thank you
foreign
is taking out
here
that's fine
so it looks like the difference between
years and Miles commercial right yes
okay
okay being at uh roughly 153 we'll open
up the hearing on House Bill 388
relative to the number of plates for
Motor Vehicles
and the chair recognizes uh
representative uh Dan Hines who is the
sponsor of the bill
uh thank you Mr chair uh it's my name is
Dan Hines representing Tana Belford and
this bill would um
basically allow people in private
passenger vehicles to only have one
plate displayed in the car that being
the rear plate so it basically would
eliminate the front plate requirement
for private passenger vehicles and
um I do have an amendment to this bill
that I recently emailed the committee
that I just got back I did submit
um a couple copies it's very brief I'll
address that in a second but so a
private passenger vehicle is defined by
a statute um so this bill wouldn't apply
to commercials it doesn't apply to buses
it essentially reply to things people
would consider a car but my Amendment to
the bill is uh I saw the fiscal note for
this and that this would cost the state
seven hundred thousand dollars a year
which I don't really like and the reason
for that would be apparently If This
Were to be enacted the way the state
charges fees for plates is it's four
dollars for plate so presumably
um if they're still printing the same
amount of plates but only collecting
four dollars essentially that Revenue
came out to 700 000 so my simple
solution to do that is my Amendment says
that people pay the same eight dollars
um whether they get one plate or two
plates
um so the revenue and that's
um sense instance rather would remain
the same if the state were to
practically do this in a way where
they're not duplicating all the license
plates in duplicate it would actually
save the money um with our save the
state money because the cost of
producing would come down but the
revenue would come out the same so I
think ultimately with that Amendment um
it would have a positive fiscal
um
effect on the state not a negative one
and so people might say why do we need
this
um I guess one of my questions is why
not so it's New Hampshire there's many
states in the country who do not require
a front plate Mass it's my understanding
Mass sometimes that sometimes doesn't
some understanding Vermont recently
changed it so that you only need one
many states just also have for a while
only needed one
um and I don't think there's been any
issues with that uh so I think the
opposition to this bill's been filed
before and I think or a form of the
spell this one is more limited than the
other ones
um but I think the opposition was
something that law enforcement can't
essentially see people or decide how to
act and I just don't think
impracticality that's how it works so if
an officer is coming at someone in the
other direction and they don't see a
faceplate or front plate I would like to
know if the officer is turning on his
lights at that point
um because I think there's an issue with
that one the officer can't know if that
person is driving from State that
doesn't require plate and there's
nothing illegal with those people
driving in New Hampshire the officer
can't tell at that point if someone has
a template because those only go on the
rear um paper so an officer could say
well I don't see a sticker he must be
from New Hampshire get behind turn on
his lights then by the time he gets
behind the car you notice oops shouldn't
stopped that person
um so I don't think it's an issue
particularly where it's my understanding
officers use essentially license
identification or a plate essentially
identification to sleep things that way
um so that's I just don't think there's
a harm in doing that but there are
benefits so my car so recently got
another Tesla but Tesla's do not by
default have a good spot or a bracket
for a front plate it's sort of
Impractical for me to put one on there's
some aftermarket things that people do
but out of the factory it doesn't have
that and the DMV he has sort of weird
issues related to factory things but
it's my understanding or I had an issue
that when I try to get it inspected it's
a different rule than the law and it
became a whole issue they didn't want to
pass the car
um so a separate issue but also front
plates can decrease the value of certain
Vehicles particularly Imports or Exotics
or high ends where there just is not a
plate and people are somehow
retrofitting a plate in there and I
think there is an environmental issue on
this uh so particularly depending on the
car a lot of cars are designed
especially nowadays they're designed for
minimal it's an engineering thing to get
the minimum wind resistance so depending
on where this front plate is if it's
like if there's no spot for it
particularly in like half of it's near
the ground or something like that I
think that can cause some issues
ultimately leading to less fuel mileage
so it might be minor still is a thing
also more on the minor environmental
impact if we're producing less plates I
think that's just the more valuable use
of resources so I would ask that you
adopt this and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you very much any questions from
the committee representative Sinclair
thank you
do you have an exact number of how many
states there are that do not require
a front plate uh last subject I did
submit written testimony to the
committee however it was like late last
night so I'll double check the number I
don't want to give the wrong number I
think it might have been around 10 or so
if I'm 20 okay 20.
thank you
any other questions
representative C
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative uh the question I have uh
relates to people who put the uh covers
over the plate
that are supposedly transparent or
whatever but that some of them are even
intended so it's very hard to read what
would you um would you want to comment
on that is how that might relate to this
bill yeah so I so uh I'm not changing
the text of the present law where the
last sentence says the plate shall be
kept clean so I suggest that that
doesn't comply with that there are also
department of safety rules that address
that on the transparency
um so this wouldn't affect that at all
if I guess if they aren't required to
have a front plate yes if they want to
put one and make it less than 100
readable it wouldn't be a violation but
if they were to keep their rear plate in
such a fashion where it's not
transparent dirty or something like that
that would still be illegal If This Were
to pass
any other questions representative Staub
thank you
still go through the toll booth and uh
did does the reader read the license
plate there and how would that work if
you didn't have a license plate on the
front of your vehicle yep so it's my
understanding the New Hampshire Easy
Pass they have cameras it's my
understanding the cameras only pick up
the rear plate uh so if someone from the
state wants to correct that but that's
my understanding so I don't think this
would have any effect at all on that
any other questions
not seeing any thank you thank you
at this point the chair would like to
recognize
um Michael Granger
who would like to speak for two minutes
and he supports the bill
uh thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh if I'm I'm going to be
discussing something a little bit
different than front license plate but
it relates to the front license plates
if you read RSA chapter
261-75 it states the following quote
the director may make special rules
relative to the number of plates the
location of said plate or plates on the
vehicle and the material and design
thereof end quote so that's the existing
law the reason I bring attention to this
is because the people are becoming
increasingly concerned about the
rule-making authority of unelected
government employees as such it seems
appropriate to limit rulemaking
Authority as much as possible unless
there's a really compelling reason to
give an unelected person the right to
make rules that can result in monetary
fines so the text of the current
legislation gives broad rule making
power to the director the director is
Not Elected there are fines for failing
to abide by the rules so this scenario
results in citizenry getting fined due
to the actions of people who are not
themselves elected
uh this is counter to the spirit of
representative government it may seem
minor but in if people are more
concerned about this nowadays than they
have in the past so it would be a step
in the right direction to sort of
take whatever power that is uh you know
anything that results in monetary fines
against citizens and if possible put it
in with the legislature so that it's uh
their representatives that are making
that sort of decision and uh not uh
government employees uh making up the
decision there so that is why I request
you vote OTP on this bill
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
not seeing any thank you representative
thank you very much
chair at this point would like to
recognize John Cochran from the New
Hampshire D.O.T
who opposes the bill
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is John Corcoran
and I'm the ministry of the Bureau of
turnpikes and for the New Hampshire
D.O.T the department has concerns with
the proposed Bill requiring one license
plate and passenger vehicle
this problem presents mainly with our
toll system the front license plate will
no longer be required and no longer be
available for us to capture a violation
capture image with our violation
enforcement system which allows us to
collect toll from the customers who
don't have a transponder
as you know the turnpike system is
critical to the dot and the state's
Transportation Network it operates under
an Easy Pass system and that consists of
35 toll agencies 19 states to provide
seamless efficient effective ways to
collect toll from in-state reticent
residents and out of state residents
particularly for open road Towing and
All Electronics only
the turnpike system operates as a
Enterprise fund with all this Revenue
collected on the system must be used on
the system the revenue is used to fund
the system's operation maintenance The
Debt Service the renewal renewal
replacement program and the capital
expansion program which is in a 10-year
plan
all the revenue from the turnpike system
goes right back into the turnpike system
last year in fiscal year 22 we collected
122 million of toll Revenue which is
about 112 million transactions of those
transactions where no transponder was
read the license plate of the vehicles
captured resulted in 13 million 500
acceptable images
of those acceptable images are Easy Pass
back office provide uh vendor use 53
percent of those were from the front
license plate
for a night an image toll which is
matching up the license plate to a
person's Easy Pass account a seven day
to pay account license plate account or
for invoice processing
it is very concerning the dot with a
high potential Revenue loss of a of a
front license plate no longer required
the department relies on the
availability of both plates to provide
the highest capture rate of the license
plate many times on rear license plates
they are blocked by bike racks trailers
and other apparatuses also a lot of
times on the license plates there's snow
on them mud on them debris on them
sometimes it depends on a time of the
year and a camera angle we lose license
plates images cut a sun glare
um all these blocked images or
unreadable images is lost toll Revenue
to us
the ability to have redundancy to read
each of front and rear is maximize our
collection of toll Revenue
when the valid transponder is not read
in the lanes
in addition to these reasons we also
have 36 Lanes out in our toll plaza that
do not have rear cameras so this would
cost us additional four hundred thousand
dollars to install cameras in those
Lanes
this concludes my testimony and I'm open
for any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
so if you have 36 Lanes I'd only read
license plates and other states only
have rare license plates they're getting
through free is that true or not those
are typically in our cash lanes that are
only the front license plates and we use
those a lot for the no funds because we
send them an invoice so usually there's
customers there collecting toll so
representative Sinclair
so thank you and I will want to follow
up I just want to be clear because he
asked a very good question so you're
saying that the the toll Gates or the
the tolls that
only read the back that don't read the
back those are where there's an
attendant yes those are where there's a
tendon
good reason for keeping the attendance I
guess that's a statement
um
we know how many of these vehicles are
coming into this state where there's
only one plate are you suggesting that
the state is losing an awful lot of
money due to sun glare snow bicycle
racks that sort of stuff on on these
automatic tolls
we have a potential losing the money
with because a lot of times in the back
the rear license plate the bike racks
and stuff
um block the license plate so we utilize
the front license plate
I you didn't answer my question so are
you suggesting that we're losing a lot
of money is what I'm asking the state
not right now because we collect both
front and rear license plates oh
from states that only have one license
plate in the rear
we could be losing I don't think there's
that many states that travel in New
Hampshire that have the one license
plate
any other questions from the committee
representative Coker thank you Mr
chairman um do you do you have like an
have you guys done an estimate I mean do
you have this statistics on like when
like how much you might lose or is this
just kind of a best guess
um our Easy Pass back office vendor out
of all the images they review they take
usually the best image and stuff and 50
of them fits through Center out of the
front license plate we use the front
license plate majority of the time but
if the front license plate was
unavailable would you lose that other
person would losing majority of that
money so like a state like Florida which
only ha you know doesn't have the front
license plate they're losing 50 of the
revenue through or do they have
different technology that makes it
easier to capture the rear plate I mean
I'm not sure about Florida system so
okay
any other questions from the committee
representative C
thank you Mr chairman uh
my question has to do with uh the uh
plastic covers that some people put over
license plates
does that interfere with the cameras
being able to read them
it doesn't interfere with taking
pictures of the cameras but sometimes
those do block the license plate numbers
in the state and it's hard to read those
too
any other questions
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir for
taking the question
do we have available a list of the
states that only require a rear-facing
plate because there's some I I don't
know what those states are
all I know is um I read an article on
Pennsylvania Turnpike when they went all
electronic tolling they're having a big
issue because the only issue they don't
have front license plates and they're
trying to go to their legislation to
change it to two license plate because
they're losing a lot of money and in
that article it said they were one of 18
states I don't know if that's no
you can see
but yes as a follow-up then uh if
someone has that information it looks
like somebody's looking for it just get
make it available to the committee
please
Saturday thank you no problem
any other questions from the committee
not saying none thank you
chair like to recognize uh John drewery
who is requesting uh four minutes and he
opposes the bill
foreign
thank you very much Mr chair and members
of the committee for taking the time to
listen to me uh this is the third year
in a row you've uh that I've been here
to do this
um and uh I retired uh last May
um and was out to pasture and this bill
means so much to me to
um to oppose it because of the way it
helps law enforcement so much that I
came back to testify today and on behalf
of you and I appreciate the honor uh to
do so on behalf of the New Hampshire
Chiefs of Police Association
I have provided you with written packets
um that's probably similar to the ones
you've had in your past years past if
you would like to shorten my testimony
um I'm obviously opposing HP 388 as well
as HB 393 in my written testimony but
I'm more than happy to stay for the
afternoon for you to testify on the
later bill that the pleasure of of the
committee
so I'm not going to bore you with
repeating my written testimony it is
riveting testimony that will put you to
sleep tonight
but a few of the highlights are I'm a
car guy I like cars I've got some grease
under my nails
um and uh I just like the front play
but it is so important for law
enforcement in my career I was a member
of the regional accident reconstruction
team
um I must admit to you that I love front
license plates
um over the years it has made my job so
much easier Route 11 uh 75 and 153 are
main state roads that run through
Farmington
um and uh when neighboring police
departments would issue a be on the
lookout for it was so much easier just
to be able to find the right car looking
for that front plate instead of trying
to turn a cruiser across the road to get
a visual a lot of the cars
um have the recess part of the real
license plates
as one of my colleagues just testified
too and it's tough to get a view on that
as they sit back underneath the trunk
lid
the crimes that we've solved are
numerous I found front license plates at
many accident scenes
we had them imprinted on other vehicles
and it was perfect on a hit and run case
where that license plate is right there
on the bumper of the other vehicle and
the person had taken off and it gives us
a wonderful starting point I even had it
on the vinyl siding of a house where
someone had gone across lost control of
their vehicle went across a lawn hit a
house and there was that front license
plate imprinted on the vinyl siding of
the house
and it just made our lives so much
easier
um
I understand
um you know looking at at nice cars and
and I had the pleasure of purchasing a a
nice hard top convertible that I had to
drill two holes in to put my front
license plate on but I proudly did it
because I stand behind that so much that
it just helped us out so much over the
year
New Hampshire license plates are
reflective they stand out really well
you could see them coming and and I
challenge you during the evening as you
drive home take a peek at the oncoming
cars and you'll see how well that New
Hampshire license plate stands out to be
able to be read
um
and um
you know we've had cars involved in
robberies the car would pull into a
business and the cameras of the
convenience store or the grocery store
uh was able to capture that front
license plate for us uh had it only been
a real license plate we would have just
had a description of a car to go on
um
and uh
as my colleague said at the tolls
um you know it I think it would cost the
state some money to lose the front
license plate
aerodynamically speaking I've been
blessed with two children that are both
engineers and one that married an
engineer who's currently doing her
doctorate at MIT in speaking with them
the aerodynamics of the wind resistance
of having a front plate and removing
that front plate is is very negligible
and in my written testimony of I've
outlined that but I don't want to bore
you with that that information
um
just in looking over some of the high
points
I provided you some documentation of you
know how that front plate does look on a
car there is universal light Universal
license plate relocators that can be
used
um basically you pop out the little tow
hook and the bracket fits right onto
there to keep the license plate from
having to add holes into your vehicle
a news update from the Department of
Justice and the AG
goes into on the last page of it
a vehicle that was involved in The
Disappearance of Harmony Montgomery
was that the real license plate happened
to be a skew and helped lead some
information into that and I provided you
that documentation as well
uh in the Vermont retailers Association
at Grocers uh actually opposed their
bill and I think they went to a
one-plate state at one point and have
now gone back to a two-plate state I I
believe they are a two plate State now
um and then in the written testimony
there
um they just say the majority of the
thefts occurring
um and the uses of two license plates
increases the opportunity of catching
perpetrators later
um I don't want to bore you with uh with
highlighting my written testimony and I
greatly appreciate the opportunity to uh
come out of my past year and come before
you today on a topic that is uh it just
is so incredibly important to my heart
even though I hate putting two holes in
a bumper of a car
um it just helps us out so greatly
um and I'd be more than happy to take
any questions that you may have and
thank you for the time
thank you very much any questions of the
committee
not seeing any thank you
thank you very much Mr chair and
committee
chair now like to recognize Lieutenant
Jay O'Leary who's requesting of five
minutes
who opposes the bill
sure
does include
some information that was provided by
the national Sheriff's Association in
2016.
law enforcement officials are charged
with numerous responsibilities including
the enforcement of laws that frequently
involve the use of motor vehicles and
other equipment Motor Vehicles are used
in 70 percent of all the serious crimes
committed in the United States and the
quick discovery of such Vehicles can
help solve such crimes
traffic enforcement activities including
the use of automated license plate
readers have proved invaluable in the
detection and apprehension of
individuals involved in crimes or
potential potential terrorist activities
all means of initial identification
including front and rear reflective
license plates are essential
front and rear fully reflective license
plates are a key component of quickly
and accurately identifying vehicles I
have personally been involved in a
number of homicide investigations in
which the suspect has fled the state and
had not been and had it not been for a
license plate reader the discovery of
the suspect's location would have been
significantly delayed the lack of having
a front plate makes that Discovery much
more difficult
conversely I recall a fatal hit and run
investigation where we were able to
gather a few high quality surveillance
videos of the suspect vehicle in this
case the vehicle was not displaying a
front license plate this had a great
impact on the investigation as not only
could we not identify the vehicle we
couldn't conclude the state in which the
vehicle was registered this
significantly impacted the time it took
to identify the vehicle and its driver
time which can be used to falsify or
hide evidence or Worse commit further
crimes and impact Public Safety
even without the benefit of quantitative
data related to license plate
identification it is reasonable to
conclude that the use of front and rear
license plate increased the probability
to accurately identifying a motor
vehicle in multiple and diverse
situations
concludes my testimony I'll take any
questions
thank you so much any questions from the
committee representative sellers thank
you Mr chair
is this your testimony or coming from
the state police
it's coming from the state police I'm
conveying it from State Police the
personal uh stories that I shared were
mine okay thank you
any other questions
not seeing any oh
representative Sinclair
I have to give them full attention
um
knowing that State Police agencies
across the country all work together
we're exchanging ideas and stuff like
that do you have any idea how it is that
I guess now 21 states in the country
only have the one license plate in the
back and that's not that not only
includes States like Florida but now I
hear Ohio is just dropped there so I'm
just wondering what the the Scuttle is
between all of State Police agencies
with regards to that thank you
representative Sinclair I appreciate the
question
um I don't unfortunately have any
information to share with you about that
I haven't had discussions with other
state police police agencies regarding
that but I do know because I recall that
Massachusetts did at one point in time
become a two-plate state so I did make
an inquiry to the state and uh they did
confirm that in 1987 they did move from
a single to a dual plate in order to
support law enforcement so that's the
only state that I'm aware of
thank you for your question any further
questions
not seeing any thank you thank you
okay that was our last speaker so at
this point I'm going to close the public
hearing
on HP 388 our next bill will be HB 393
and we'll start in a few minutes
okay being at uh 225 we will start the
public hearing on HB
393 which is permitting a motor vehicle
operator to use only a rear license
plates
at this point the chair like to
recognize our representative J.R Howell
who is uh the sponsor of the bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record representative
hole
serving the towns of Dunbarton hooks at
Allenstown and epsom
the bill before you
this could be my shortest testimony on
the record I could say ditto closing and
leave right there is it is very similar
to representative Hinesville that we
just discussed much of the testimony is
parallel the difference in HB 393 versus
three whatever the other one was 388 is
commercial vehicles would be allowed
right in addition to
um just private passenger vehicles I did
email at the request of members of the
committee
um some text that you should have in
your inboxes already regarding the 21
states that have a single license plate
only
um and for the record
um Ohio in 2020 just adopted a similar
measure
I am in full support of and I did not
testify in favor of 388 I'm in full
support of that bill I believe there are
some
some similarities between the bills that
could be worked out
whether it's the Tesla owners whether
it's the sports car owners there's a
number of other car owners that for some
reason don't want to damage their car
the antique cars out there whatever
it's past time to start thinking about a
solution where the rear license plate is
the only one and for for the record
everybody who gets a personalized vanity
plate in the state
guilty uh even my trailer guilty
um there is
um right a period of time somewhere
between a couple of days and six weeks
or so where you're driving around only
with a rear license plate with some
piece of plastic as my town clerk told
me to do right wrap it in plastic it'll
last longer that way it doesn't like get
destroyed by the weather I'm like oh
that's a good idea so
we routinely do this we have to solve
the problem for rear placement license
plates only okay
there is no reason in a state that just
adopted in 2018 a privacy amendment to
the Constitution that was overwhelmingly
adopted by 81 percent okay to continue
to allow the front license plate skin
readers and some of the other things the
prior testimony talked about
this is a privacy issue there is a
reason that people would rather just
have one license plate it does allow the
police officers and the state police to
identify the car if they have a reason
to pull it over and to know who's in
there who owns it whether it's still
current registration is still current
um all of that still happens with a rear
identification
um the the tax revenue
um to Mr Saint or representative
Sinclair's comment right we have to
solve this problem for the other 21
states that might drive through New
Hampshire anyway so we can't just
dismiss that we haven't bothered to put
license plate readers at 36 different
locations at the cost of four hundred
thousand dollars
um that seemed High by the way being on
finance 36 locations at ten thousand
dollars a piece
um we should sharpen our pencil the
anyway I would ask that you would pass
this bill and allow this state to
continue to show that we are truly a
Live Free or Die State thank you
thank you representative any questions
of the committee
not seeing any thank you thank you
chair at this point I'd like to
recognize representative Dan Hines who
is supports the bill in like one minutes
thank you Mr chair uh Dan Hines
representing town of Bedford I just
wanted to touch on the Easy Pass issue a
great representative Hall it would be
nice to find a solution but in the
alternative since I was proposing an
amendment to my bill and if that I would
also support that amendment to this bill
that the people pay the same eight
dollars whether they get one or two
plates uh I wouldn't object if there
were an amendment saying that this would
only apply to people have easy passes
um because I don't know that vehicles
have a problem with easy passes so if we
want to further limit to that it would
potentially lead to more Revenue to the
state although I think the solution
might be different but if the committee
were to adopt that or consider that I
think that would be fine
thank you any questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
at this point the chair like to
recognize drawn Drury
who just requesting four minutes and he
opposes the bill
thank you
we're good but good
um if you want to take my previous
testimony uh in conjunction I don't want
to bore you uh with that
um if you would like to hear the states
that currently that was what I was
quickly Googling out there according to
the New Hampshire rather the Insurance
Institute I'm more than happy to read
those into the record for you the
closest state is Pennsylvania to us
um that uh is a single plate State and
and as I believe the trooper said they
were having problems with their tolling
system as well
um but my testimony would remain the
same
um and as I say uh I'm proud to live in
a two-plate state
um and I just find that the the
advantages are just so overwhelming for
uh for law enforcement
um to keep us in that uh Avenue
um and uh I would just respectfully ask
that you find these bills in expedient
to legislate
um on behalf of the New Hampshire Chiefs
and Police Association and I greatly
appreciate your time once again
any I'd be more than happy to take any
questions could you send those the list
of 20 states to the committee here and
we'll pass it around I can make sure
that happens to you appreciate that any
questions from the committee
representative Sinclair i i before I ask
it is the gentleman from the turnpike is
going to testify again
I have yes okay I'll I'll wait for him
then thank you representative Fox
thank you Mr chair
um you indicated that Pennsylvania was
the nearest State to us and that they
were experiencing some some issues do
you know what those issues were
uh thank you very much for your question
it's just as I had heard as you did I
thought the trooper mentioned they were
having some tolling problems as well
um with it and uh but if he's going to
testify I would I would uh relay that
question to him
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you thank you very
much for your time
the chair like to recognize uh Mikey
Levitz
maybe like five minutes and he supports
the bill
my name is Mikey Levis I'm in favor of
both the uh was it 388 and 393 but I
chose to only speak on this one because
it's a little I guess broader this this
bill isn't really an issue for me I
don't entirely mind putting a front
plate on I don't drive sports cars or
anything like that so it's not a big
deal but I do like the idea of having
that option as other people have said
there are 20 20 or so states that don't
require a front plate Ohio being the
most recent one to make that change this
whole debate has been hashed out
numerous times and
we find that it isn't really an issue
Ohio Pennsylvania Michigan and all these
other states they are able to solve the
crimes
and as much as it may help solving
crimes it also
when police are enforcing this law it
does distract them from other issues if
they're looking for front plates they're
not looking for
other driving issues or they're not
working on actual violent crimes which
is an issue
so for some reason there is a special
exception to our fundamental rights when
it comes to Vehicles no one would ever
say that you have to wear a plate on
your shirt or on the back of your shirt
to identify you we do have that issue
coming in with facial recognition but
that would be insane most people would
find that insane
if we need front plates to identify a
car why not plates on the sides too why
not a plate on the roof
if there's an issue of identifying
Vehicles you have to think about all
these different perspectives
and then the the
gentleman from the the Department of
Transportation said there are issues
with toll Revenue
trailers only have rear plates so
they don't have a front plate so if
you're collecting if you're if they're
scanning the rear plate and they can't
get that there's no front plate on the
trailer either
you also have to look at the other side
of it he says they may lose Revenue
things don't always work out perfectly I
have to say honestly tough cookies
I once went through a toll in New York
and they sent me the camera camera like
notice in the mail that said this is
your plate and this is what you owe I
was driving a
sedan and it said it had three axles the
car does not have three axles it had two
axles so I sent in the dispute form
and they acknowledged the dispute
and then sent me another notice that I
still owe it
so I sent I went through that whole
thing so you have to look at both sides
of the thing yes the the
the the Department of Transportation
might miss out on some revenues but
they're also people who are
getting fined or told unnecessarily and
then they don't always they're not like
me and they are not going to fight it
so we have to look at both sides of this
so just because the state might lose a
little bit of Revenue
you have to
think about how that's not
always important
I do recognize there are issues with
this I'm not
super gung-ho about this bill as other
bills but I do think it's a good bill
and I'd like to see either one pass if
it's the other one that's great if it's
this one that's even better so I think
it's a good step forward again there's
20 states that have this I don't think
they have higher crime rates than we do
I don't think their law enforcement has
as many issues maybe they have a few
issues but I think they managed to get
it done and I think I you know I believe
in our law enforcement's ability to
solve crimes so I think this is a kind
of a ridiculous issue to
make that distinction thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you
chair like to recognize John Cochran
from the New Hampshire D.O.T who would
like uh five minutes and he opposes the
bill
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
um will you accept my testimony from a
previous bill it's pretty much the same
except
um there is one thing in regards to
commercial vehicles
um we definitely do not uh we oppose
this bill because on commercial vehicles
a lot of times they're pulling trailers
and we're only allowed to invoice the
first owner of the vehicle we cannot
invoice the trailer so we need the front
license plate to invoice any of the
tractor trailers or people who are
pulling trailers so we
oppose the bill because of the
commercial side of this
thank you very much any questions from
the committee representative Sinclair
thank you
um
so a a car not a commercial vehicle but
from Ohio could be pulling a trailer too
correct yes
follow-up
you were talking about the loss of tolls
um because of the single license plate
and and I'm not encouraging a change to
this but I all I could think about was
the hundreds of thousands of motorcycles
to go through those tall riding season
with just one plate in the rear and is
the state experiencing a loss of
hundreds of thousands of dollars because
of that
I'm not sure how much the loss is with
more Cycles but more Cycles are tough to
pick up you know their license plates
and stuff and also they have
transponders and they waive them and
it's hard to pick up their transponders
too so there is issues with the
motorcycles yeah
thank you back to the attendance thank
you
representative sellers
thank you Mr
so a car or a vehicle towing a
Recreation vehicle
does that get picked up
uh you mean the uh
um we would no we take a picture of the
license plate of the camper but we
cannot use that license plate to invoice
um we can only invoice the owner of the
vehicle the truck not the trailer
or the or the the car was pulling the
trailer
so you do collect a fee for the trailer
though that's what I'm getting oh yes if
they're the toll yeah they get charged
extra axles
follow up I I have one other question
which is
you know how many vehicles go through
the
the tolls so you know how much you
collect so you know how much you don't
collect
right I mean
yes I mean do you mean there is a lot of
like
when you're into electronic tolling
there is a percentage of loss because
you have bad images you know different
stuff like that and you right now are
they call it leakage or a loss it's
around two to three percent you know
with AET it can get higher just because
there's a everybody's going through
there's no cash collection
any further questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you
thank you
okay she and I like to recognize uh
staff sergeant Tom conlon who's asking
for three minutes
who opposes the bill
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for having me today yeah my
name's uh Tom Collins I work for the
state police I work out of Troop G
Barracks I'm the assistant troop
Commander there
so we've heard testimony today both
these two uh very similar bills you
heard from a former crash
Reconstructionist you heard from a
homicide investigator so I'm going to be
very brief I'll speak from a patrol
perspective because I work Patrol from
the vast majority of my career down in
troop a on 95 and route 101.
so work control you get a vast majority
of we'll call them citizen complaints or
on hazards operators you know suspected
dby Vehicles involved in Hit and Run and
from my experience the license plate is
the best identifying information
you can on your way home today look on
the highways you can find every single
make model in color duplicated many
times so the license plate is essential
to identifying the correct vehicle and
obviously deleting one of those plates
would be kind of that Effectiveness in
half
as far as the commercial motor vehicle
aspect obviously not all commercial
motor vehicles but a vast majority pull
the trailer in some sort of
configuration and furtherness of the
business so this would uh severely
inhibit that ability to properly
identify those trucks
thank you
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative sellers thank you thanks
chair the
dude and
I'd like to know how many crimes I saw
because of the front plate do you have
those statistics thank you for your
question I do not I'm not sure if that
would is really quantifiable except
doing a case-by-case search
representative Sinclair thank you
I get the the thing about the two plates
I really do but what mystifies me is why
there's and I asked the other Trooper
there's the lieutenant why there's not
or is there a national push between law
enforcement agencies to require every
state to have two license plates on
Motor Vehicles
thank you for your questioning I
apologize I I do not know of any
committee or or a national push for that
could
you could always lead it
thank you very much any further
questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
at that point the point this is our last
speaker on this bill so at this point
I'm going to close the public hearing on
HP 393.
yep okay
not nothing I just want to make a recess
a couple of announcements for next week
hey yeah
you're supposed to be yeah
he did I'm just making an announcement
for the committee
everybody
hello
yeah I just want to give you give you a
heads up for next week um
we are going to keep Tuesday for next
week I have had a conversation with the
chair of Public Works we may have to do
a trade or two here and there just to be
fair we might have a Wednesday or two uh
but I'll give you as much notice as
possible but for next week we're Tuesday
uh we've got one more early Bill all the
bills we heard today were early which
means they need to go to a second
committee uh there's one left and we'll
hear that next Tuesday morning and I'll
fill the morning with other public
hearings uh but plan on our first
executive session on at least all our
early bills next Tuesday afternoon
so just for your planning purposes if
there's no other questions thank you
representative Gorski
I'm going to put them all on and as we
discussed I don't have to take them up
if if there's something pertinent
yep
but if I put them up and the progress is
made we can do it
you know how it works if we're not ready
I do not have to open the executive
session
yeah but you know you know how it works
the more you can put on there the more
we have the ability to cover so
foreign
so if there's no questions thanks
everybody see you next week
foreign